[Music]
hello and welcome to the coverage of the
2016 US Junior close Chess Championship
coming to you live from the chess club
and Scholastic Center of St Louis I'm
aiv fredman here with Grandmasters Ben
fold hi Ben and Grandmaster alahandra
Ramirez who is going to be by the
computer and giving us lots of insights
and info and and uh yeah this is going
to be an amazing year with potentially
the strongest open ever as far as
participants and terms of titles and
ratings uh we notice that the lowest
rated player in the tournament is
posting a 252 USCF rating we have two
grand Masters we have uh six Bonafide
IMS and two IM elect uh who already
crossed the 2400 and thus our guaranteed
their title assumingly presumingly in
the uh Baku Olympiad the Congress after
the Olympia this year uh what do you
think Ben how do you compare this
tournament is so amazing with the ones
that you played I know that you played
in five tournament five such
championships yourself well it's great
to be here with you and Alejandro here
at the US junior Championship I remember
you know a long time ago I was a player
and uh well things have gotten a lot
stronger since then um when I played my
first junior Championship in
uh I mean there was one player over 2500
and there was nobody else over 2400 I
was in my 2200s and and I scored minus
one I was plus some with two rounds to
go I was one of the average players and
it's not like that anymore now all the
players are not only Grand Masters and
IMS a lot of the IMs are grandm strength
the FMS have already getting their IM
title very soon and I think all of these
players over the next two or three years
will become Grand Masters and Junior
chess in America is really shining and
this is a really good example we have a
great tournament here in this great
facility where we also have the S field
cup us Championship US Women's Champion
ionship the US junior Championship
deserves a great venue like this to
Showcase their great talents and how
strong chess has come in the US for
juniors over the last few years
absolutely it's an amazing time for
junior chess Scholastic chess in general
and well I would say chess in general
because we thef has three of the top 10
players in the world and I think D just
trickles down all the way to Scholastic
chess and as we are talking we're seeing
a uh running picture of the venue the
beautiful venue beautiful venue indeed
is the uh boardroom of the chess club in
Scholastic Center on the second floor of
the club uh that venue already uh hosted
several tournaments such as US Women's
and open Chess championships uh several
tournaments such as the sful cup and
matches among top players of the world
we had world champions and the current
world champion and uh ex- world
champions uh playing there and I'm sure
it's going to be very inspiring
comparing this to when I was playing in
the Juniors uh you know often we would
be like at a college campus in a dorm
sharing rooms trying to find some SP to
play we we weren't playing on dgt boards
with wood pieces if you know what I mean
and you know with now we have great
prizes and of course the winner goes to
the US championship and we had that
prize also but there weren't the other
extra prizes and nice playing venue and
nice hotels and great Arbiters and a
great and food and drinks for the
players things have really stepped up in
the last few years absolutely and we're
going to talk in detail about the prize
fund later but enough to say that the
top prize in this tournament is $6,000
just to give people idea when I was
talking to uh resident Grandmaster Robin
vancer who is coming from Holland and I
mentioned that to him he just stood
paused for a second and said that this
is just about the top rise for the Dutch
championship for Ben enough said easy
and nothing mention this it's not even
clear that's the best prize going to the
US Championship next year playing
against players that normally you normal
Grand Masters don't have a chance to
even even face let alone three of the
top 10 and they guaranteed like in the
in the 2016 US Championship the last
place prize which is not necessarily
what they're going to get they can do
better than that was $4,000 on top right
and the right to play imagine being
invited to a tournament category 15 or
so playing against three of the top
players in the world maybe even higher
than that and being paid $4,000 to do
that on top of this prize no it's
amazing and uh the reigning Champion
akot Chandra obviously had a bad us
Championship he'd like to go back and
and prove himself and a learning
experience try to be try to win two and
it's going to be very difficult this
time absolutely and just to give you an
idea of how strong it is let's look at
take a look at today's pairings for the
first round of the Championships and
let's take a look we see that newcomer
Nicholas ccha FM but I am elect is
playing I am Alexander OSI another
newcomer in Michael Brown is facing the
reigning Champion I am AKA Chandra uh
Luke Haron valti is playing against
Grandmaster and the newly crowned eagle
scout Kaden trop was going to be
celebrated later this year L this week
uh strong I am ruang Lee who has been
having a scorching summer is playing the
highest ridden and the heavy favorite
for this tournament Grandmaster Jeffrey
Shan and the youngster of the tournament
aand leang is facing another one of the
veterans I am Michael bodak and for the
key match up of the day why don't we go
to Grand Master Alejandra Ramirez for
some
insight thank you abiv before this
tournament started I think it was
obvious that the matchup everybody
wanted to see was ruley against Jeffrey
Shong and let me explain why ruing comes
from an amazing summer he won the open
in Las Vegas only a couple of weeks ago
ahead of many many Grand Masters he had
a fantastic result in the world open
where he was just half a point shy of a
GM norm and had he won his last game he
would have won the entire tournament one
of the top opens in the entire world but
even that fails in comparison to Jeffrey
Shan summer he has crossed 2640 in the
feeder rating list that puts him at the
top of the top of the Junior list and
he's I think number four currently in
the in the under 20 in the world and on
top of that he just won the capablanca
premere tournament in Cuba he's had an
amazing summer he seems to be
skyrocketing that comes after having a
really good performance in the US
Championship where he scored 50% this is
going to be the game to see and this is
a rivalry both Jeffrey and ruang are
from the Dallas area and they have
played an amazing 37 times 17 wins for
Jeffrey 17 wins for ruy Fang we see
Jeffrey on the screen right now and only
three draws so a very bloodthirsty set
of games there between these two
youngsters from the Dallas area it's
going to be a tiebreaker game here in
the first round of the US Junior o
championship and a many would say this
actually would set the pace whoever wins
in this game would become a not very
heavy favorite but definitely a favorite
to win the event this is one of the key
matchups of the entire tournament and
certainly the most important game of
round one thank you Alejandro and indeed
it's hard to disagree uh when such a
matchup occurs already on the first
round that clearly sends the signal that
there are no free launches in this
tournament every game is going to be
very meaningful for the out for the for
the final results and it's really you
can say that maybe some players are
favorit but there and maybe you can say
that some players are maybe not
absolutely favorites but you can tell
that they have already have the sculps
of very strong players under their belt
and anybody can beat anybody in such a
tournament no I agree and um also the
fighting Spirit of the players uh which
Alejandra was referring to earlier uh I
played ruang Lee last month in a norm
tournament here and it was the first
round and I thought he was going to be
the strongest player I would face in
that event I had the white pieces I
offered an early draw as I like to do
against the better players he refused
with the black pieces very competitive
game which he ended up winning and
that's the way he plays chess and even
though there's a third 30 move draw rule
in this tournament they players can't
agree to a draw until both sides have
made 30 moves that's um and this
tournament is going to be somewhat
unnecessary because these are fighting
players we don't see early draws and
especially in the junior Championship
but these juniors in particular they
don't they don't like draws they play
Fighting Chess and I was amazed by the
statistic that Alejandro gave 37 games
only three draws that's just crazy yeah
that's very very unusual 1717 we can say
that today's game is going to be the uh
um temporary rubber game against between
the two because I'm guessing this
robbery is going to continue for years
to come and uh it's just phenomenal
we're really expecting lots of decisive
games everybody has something to prove
first of all as we say the coveted first
prize with a with a entry the guaranteed
entry to the US Championship but also
people are after raising their ratings
after after titles and let's go again
back to Alejandro amirz to even more
inside guys I agree completely this is a
very strong tournament but let's not not
forget this is a very young tournament
even for a US Junior we don't have
players that are at the top of the
rating list Crossing 18 19 years I mean
the top players are 13 14 15 years old
Jeffrey Shong is only 15 ruing is still
14 he hasn't crossed 15 this year just
yet and let's talk about a wander leang
who's also one of the very strong
players in this tournament he just
scored a GM Norman El Salvador maybe a
couple of months ago he's had a series
of good results he's only 13 years old I
think that he's one of the players to
watch I'm also going to be paying close
attention to his game today absolutely
Alejandro again very very smart insight
and uh we can see that the like you said
the younger players are the ones that
actually the higher rated ones and
mainly because the players who are at
slight slightly older are U Already
choosing a very corrupted way of life
meaning they chose College over chess
and that is quite terrible um you got to
be chess coaches like us to call College
a corrupt exactly of course we everybody
understands that we do it tongue and
cheek and uh of course we are
representing CH so we're trying to uh be
very uh U very biased on the topic and
uh yeah again one thing that really
makes this tournament unique in my eyes
is the diversity of those people and
when I was reading their bios and
thinking about the people that I know
less all because some of them I know
very well I was amazed to see that okay
we have the known fact that um Luke
Haron valetti who at the age of what 15
16 he's already a senior in UCLA stud
having a double major in Applied
Mathematics I think computer science and
in a spare time he is programming for a
startup in Silicon Valley uh you have
someone like Nicholas cheze the newcomer
who is uh he has such a quiet demeanor
very soft spoken but he has a black belt
in karate you know I could have used him
sometimes in soft and car a big stick
exactly uh and still water run deep so
and many of them are so talented that
that they really have so many other
hobbies and yet they manage to really
become the best in in the best in the
country at CH yes because king of Czech
he just did a very good tournament at
the world open which just finished last
week we have some of the players here
coming coming from Philadelphia right
and uh cck actually if he had won his
last turn I think would have tied for
first but still he won a lot of prize
money for the under 20 2450 feed day
prize and uh well had a fantastic
tournament yeah quite astonishing and
we're looking again at the live shot uh
just disappeared but let's try to see if
we can get it back a live shot of the
playing area and we can see uh Tony Rich
is making announcements now exactly the
executive director of the chess club and
also Chief TD Tony Rich is making the
obligatory uh announcements before the
round about the regulations about the
players uh that there's absolutely zero
tolerance to uh speaking and leaving the
tournament area I know the players were
wanded for electronics there's no
electronics rules boy Jeffrey and ruing
look pretty serious yes as a matter of
fact for a moment I thought it'd be
froze because they yeah and Jeffrey is
doing his famous Sphinx imitation where
he is just completely immobile in total
concentration and I know that one of the
things that I'm always amazed by Ru
Angley is that he's able to sit at the
board for hours yeah when I was watching
some of his games in the aforementioned
gmn tournament everybody's walking
around going to the kitchen getting some
drinks he is sitting and just not moving
from the chair for hours even if it's
not his move and if he's not necessarily
thinking of position he is just in in in
in complete War mode so very very very
see the assistant Arbiter Michael CER
there in the blue shirt and some of the
well-known parents and you know them
very well right good AKA chandra's
father very loyal companion and a youth
supporter of his son and uh talking
about aksha Chandra the reigning
Champion um
at when he was when he was uh I think it
was 2010 at 2010 he was 1500 wow and in
in five years he made a progress of a
th000 points with very little
instruction much of it is by himself
that's an amazing progress and he has a
beautiful blog uh Quest For gm.com That
he writes very eloquently about his
pursuit of the GM title and his um
successes and adversities along the way
very impressive definitely one of the
stronger players in the Ser he won it
last year which I think was to a
surprise to some people he was
definitely not one of the favorites he
qualified for the US Championship he
didn't have a great tournament but he's
also had a pretty decent summer he just
made his I think fifth GM Norm in the
New York International so he comes from
a very strong tournament with very good
results he's one of those players that
say say hey I haven't been showing as
much progress as maybe some of my peers
but I can still win this event I agreed
he had a very rough years Championship
but I think he took it as a learning
experience he jumped back he bounced
back he won that aform mention right
Grand Master Norm with the plus two yeah
and he is again he has a long career
ahead of him and uh we were talking
before the show Ben you have mentioned
to me how uh last year was basically
from the from the get-go a two-person
show it was it was kind of a race
between AKA Chandra and Jeffrey Shang
and I think it's it's fair to say that
this year we're not anticipating such a
such a right to me there's there's four
real favorites this tournament jeffre is
the big favorite being over 2700 USCF
course um but we also have uh well the
new Eagle Scout who'll be I guess given
that title on Wednesday the free day
there's actually if if any of you watch
you're coming to St Louis you can go to
Forest Park and we have chess table set
up and he's going to give a simultaneous
exhibition on the free day and recogniz
so Kaden tro is one of the big favorites
also over 2600 USCF a veteran of this
event at such a young age and oot
Chandra and ruang Lee those I think are
the the four that somebody expects one
of them to win but of course the other
players can anybody can win a game in
this tournament and beat anybody so
there's there's no easy games and well
I'm very excited that in the first round
we have this big match up between Ru
Angley and Jeffrey Jong and of course a
Wonder leang shouldn't be underestimated
he's also had a good summer getting a GM
norm and so young and improving so
quickly and I remember the chief Arbiter
here Tony Rich he beat Wonder a few
years ago when Tony was a lot higher
rated than a Wonder but things have
changed over the last few years
definitely definitely so this again the
tournament is shaping up to be a mon of
tournament and we see that the games
have started and uh without further Ado
let's start by visiting our first
matchup of the day and we can see that
this is going to be some sort of a close
Sicilian ruang Lee is white with the
white pieces Jeffrey is black and after
E4 C5 I'm assuming Knight C3 was played
first right yep and D6 Jeffrey is making
sure that is maintaining the option to
play uh one of the sharp Sicilians so in
case of Knight F3 or Knight E2 you could
still play uh Knight F6 and instead
rofang Le unsurprisingly because has
chosen it many times in the past is
steering towards a closest sign now
let's see how Jeffrey is going to treat
that I'm assuming that uh oh here we go
after refesh he's playing the standard
system yeah with Knight C6 and of course
G6 the bishop on the long diagonal is a
counterpart I think usually in the
junior Championship we see more open
Sicilians and close Sicilians definitely
but ruang Lee that's part of his Arsenal
playing the the close cilian I'm
assuming it's the influence of his uh
coaching and uh he has actually pretty
decent results in it I'm really curious
to see how he's going to do against uh
Jeffrey in this game one very tiny bit
that has nothing to do with today's
games is we're going to be remiss if we
didn't mention a propo eagle scouting
and and chess uh that Genie singfield uh
wife of Rex and one of the uh the
co-owner co-founder of the club is
almost single-handedly responsible to
the fact that there is now a chess
merage B merit badge uh at the Boy
Scouts and uh there are I forget how
many tens of thousands of people already
have it and it's being pursued
consistently so kudos to her for such a
a great thing and we see um occasionally
you know they have uh these things where
you can try to get the badge here at the
chess club and we see Boy Scouts coming
and we see more chess and uh the mixing
of Chess and kids it just keeps growing
and growing and do the re and Genie's
generosity and not only the financial
generosity but the the thinking about
how how do we get more kids interested
into chess and having chess camps here
having tournaments like this having Boy
Scouts get merit badges and and there's
more and more ideas that come out every
year and well Kaden tro will be I guess
the only person in the world to be a
grandm and an eagle scout right that's
that's a very unique uh double title to
hold uh and let's go now to our second
game let's see the A1
Leon
game he's playing with the white pieces
against Michael bodak and let's see what
happened here so D4 was played so I
wonder play
D4 G6 G6 a little unusual in a Junior
tournament yes we have to remember that
Michael bodak has the tendency to play
uh Sidelines odd variations the Obscure
opening here and there so anything by
him is has can be considered a surprise
and a Wonder played very classically
with E4 okay so he went into the an E4
opening all of a sudden and why can play
a lot of moves here F4 C4 C3 he just
developed both of his Knights okay and
now uh Michael changed the game a little
bit playing C6 and D5 uhuh so it's going
to be some something like in the ganza
type of system with D5 yeah and now to
prevent Bishop G4 because there's some
there's some pressure on D4 he played
the move H3 and quickly bodc played
Knight
H6 very interesting and I think the idea
is when there's a trade on e4 or G5 we
have the F5 for the Knight something
like this was shown to me a very long
time ago before any of these players
were born by Mark Ginsburg he always
wanted to play this with black play this
Knight H6 and try to get the Knight to
F5 because he's also a very unusual
thinker International master in the US
right yeah we have a lot of original
thinkers in the tournament it's not
going to be 20 moves of theory in one
minute and then start thinking I think
this is part of the fun on some games
you're going to have the theory hounds
going uh trying to prove whose novelty
on move 30 is going to win others
they're going to say hey starting on
move two or three let's put the opponent
in the thing tank and try to play some
original chest where he is completely
out of his preparation and this is a
good idea for Michael because usually
when you're a younger player and you
memorized lots of theory these unusual
Sidelines it's the older kg players
they're 19 and 20 those older K players
players can do better against the 12 13
14 year olds who don't have experience
in these Sidelines agreed absolutely
agreed and let's do uh keep uh touring
going around the horn let's see what
other games we have I'll let you pick
whichever game is next Ben okay maybe
Michael Brown I see Michael Brown is
playing against Chandra right the
newcomer against the reigning that's
right the raing champion yep let's go to
the beginning here uhuh again another
slightly unusual opening
D4 and then
E6 C4 Bishop B4 check okay seems guess
we used to play that when he was active
when he was active I'm going to
guessman yes exactly I always had
problems with D4 and tried to play all
kinds of of nonsense to take my opponent
out of the yeah and that was one of my
favorites um yeah this is something that
I would think like Jonathan Spielman
would play a lot right well they did it
with the F5 thing I don't think I had
the GU to do that only after Bishop D2
he played A5 is that what you played no
no I checken C5 and uh I see that
Alejandro is uh wanting to contribute
something so let's go back let's go to
him thanks yeah actually this bishop B4
checkline is something that I've used
quite frequently so I feel kind of
comfortable talking about it and the
idea is that can try to get some kind of
good nimso Indian positions depending on
the Move order of your opponent I've
always thought that here the move Bishop
B4 Bishop D2 is definitely the most
challenging to the black side I don't
think that Knight C3 is particularly
good uh after the move A5 which has
become very very popular in this
position actually I think Michael
already makes a slight imprecision after
the move A3 which I think is not the
best Queen takes uh Bishop takes D2
Queen takes D2 here it's black to move
and after the move Knight F6 which was
played in the game Black's eventually
going to get a very normal BOGO Indian
type of position but with two important
details inserted they move A3 and A4 in
the long R this is going to be a problem
for the white side because if I ever put
my Pawn on A4 and I somehow managed to
reinforce it it's going to be impossible
for white to break open on the queen
side or to expand on the queen side and
he's going to have some light Square
problems on this side of the board
especially because this bishop on F1
usually likes to be faned on the long
diagonal this is actually not the best
for white I I think the black actually
equalizes comfortably from the positions
stemming from uh after Knight F6 so I
think this was quite a success for aot
and going back to the other game that
you were showing uh between my Wonder
leang and Michael bodic we have a couple
of new moves actually we have uh this
position on the board and I think you
guys left it off right after uh Bishop
D3 which still looked more or less like
a normal position uh White's kind of
having a strong Center but black has the
the D5 break already on the board the
Knight could jump to F5 you would think
at some point Black's going to take the
pawn on e4 jump with the Knight to F5
pressure the D4 Pawn but nothing like
that he actually played this move
F6 after castle and retreated the Knight
to F7 a very unusual type of maneuver
here in the opening usually it's bad to
move the Knight several times in the
position the idea is that he's trying to
create some kind of solid structure try
to at some point maybe play an E5 break
confuse a Wonder try to let uh White
figure out what to do exactly this is
not a very popular variation but has
been played three times by Alexander
ratov with the black pieces a very
strong Turkish Grandmaster with
relatively good success uh I wonder play
the move Queen E2 which is relatively
unknown in the database almost everybody
chose the move Rook E1 with the idea of
pushing an E5 break Queen E2 does
something very similar but with the
Queen instead of The Rook very sharp
position in some sense because black
does have to be very careful of not be
being completely bound down if I ever
get the move E5 in and I'm unable to
develop this could be very dangerous for
black bodic has to be um aware of the
dangersous of his position he's the one
that shows this variation and he has to
show exactly what he has prepared in it
thank you Alejandro and indeed it looks
like black Bor the variation from
another Carl Khan line where um in the
exchange Caro Khan the one the way the
Fisher used to play with Bishop D3 and
C3 um again black has a times where he
chooses Knight H6 F6 Bishop G Bishop to
G7 and the Knight goes to F7 here it
seems even more logical because nothing
has been committed than the pawn there's
a knight on C3 instead of Pawn on C3 so
very exciting setup he's going to be
maybe a little cramped but uh I guess
like Alejandro mentioned he wants to
explode in the center with E5 at some
moment I'm actually surprised that uh a
wonder is not taking very much time
because was was he expecting this line
that just seems so unlikely that he
would think black would play this and
usually in the opening when your
opponent quote unquote outsmarts you or
plays something you weren't looking at
at you think like what do I know about
this and what's the right plans but he's
playing basically the same speed as his
opponent so I'm wondering does he know
this line does he know Knight H6 F6
Knight F7 very interesting question it
seems unlikely perhap perhaps we'll get
to ask him this question after the game
when he comes to for an interview um
perhaps he's just choosing logical moves
and trying to say rather than overthink
the situation just play Simple logical
moves uh develop my pieces to Natural
squares and uh take try to take
advantage of my space edge um okay and
let's go on let's move on to another
game okay
uh whichever you choose for us let's
look at this uh it looks like a grunfeld
to me uh Luke Haron vat versus uh Kaden
tro okay let's take a look at that let's
go back to the beginning okay and if and
if Matt Larson is watching I'm sure uh
he'll be very opinionate about this this
is a line that he's actually played both
sides of Matt Larson a former
participant of this very Championship a
local San uh strong master who is now
became a senior master right and made
his even his first IM Norm if I remember
correctly and also has the correct the
special he actually if he had won in the
penultimate round he would have gotten a
grand master with a round to go quite
impressive for someone who was just
2200s uh yeah until pretty recently
actually when we started working in in
2010 he was rated
1150 quite an impressive jump guess he's
competing with chundra on USF 2430 quite
quite an impressive advant so this F3
move is very interesting because white
wants to get some kind of Kings Indian
samish by playing the move E4 but before
he's played Knight C3 so white actually
has a few more options okay so so tro
plays the grinfeld very often could
couldn't have been very surprising for
either player Luke Harman valad I think
plays a lot of different stuff against
different openings he's harder to
prepare for right okay so they played
this main line of the of the gelds
Knight C3 Bishop G7 and Bishop E3 and we
see a lot of and they've made they've
made some more moves since so let's
refresh uh castles and queen D2 and this
is a line uh where we see white often
castling Queen side and playing for a
big kingside attack with H4 H5 and again
this is the kind of double-edged you
know opening position we expect to see
in the Junior with both players very
well prepared of course Kaden playing
the grinfeld doesn't know what variation
his opponent's going to play but he's
very experienced in this opening and
he's well prepared and Luke just decided
this is what I'm going to do against the
grinfeld he knew he knew what Kaden was
going to do in the opening and so this
is the line he decided on and that's why
he has a little bit more time now this
is still in his opening preparation of
course for this particular game
absolutely so definitely another welcome
opening an aggressive opening um with
anticipation of potentially again
casting on opposite sides one of the
best gifts that you can give Spectators
right because by definition that is
going to mean an attack uh an attack on
each sides a race of some sorts and uh
like you said correctly you know Cayden
is always true to his uh grinfield
Harman vti knew it and uh the
combination of
maybe Kad not really knowing what har V
is going to play but has having
tremendous experience in the opening uh
both sides must be really comfortable I
think they're both kind of happy that
that this is their top this is their
starting position that's right and uh
luk Luke's having a think here either
he's trying to remember the lines he
analyzed before the game or he couldn't
decide which line he was going to play
and he has to make a decision now that's
actually happened to me I wasn't sure
which variation I was going to play and
so I got to the game and I'm like all
right I'll choose this one exactly well
you have you I remember you telling me
that you come to the board and you
couldn't tell what first move you're
going to make4 that all that's that's
that's a that's a different issue than
than this one where I'm actually well
prepared I agreed fair enough and let's
let's continue we still have some games
that we have in touch today let's take a
look
what let's have a look at okay we
haven't
seen Chaka the newcomer versus oski
who's played here before of course and
they have an opening that I wasn't
really expecting this tournament looks
like a queen gamb but accepted mhm and
then after C4 he took on C4 and unusual
variation he played the move
B5 uhhuh yeah I've seen it somewhere of
late it used to be almost a no no move I
thought for a longest time and then of
late you've seen this being used in some
grandm games um I think that soon we're
going to visit Alejandra for some
insight on this opening and perhaps
after a look at the database but let's
take a look at is this the current
position or play so he played A4
following the fine gold rule when they
play B5 you play A4 and now he played
the move B4 immediately giving up the
the C plan right realizing that probably
you cannot keep the pawn anyways right I
mean it's just uh it's not possible to
play A6 obviously and after C6 I'm
assuming there's going to be a B3 after
the capture so probably black will have
to give up the pawn and his structure
under much worse circumstances right
either immediately or take on B5 and
then then B3 just looking very but after
B4 Bishop takes C4 black had to move E6
and usually when Black's playing B5 B4
in any kind of queen Pawn opening you're
hoping as a white you haven't played
Knight C3 yet so you're not losing a
Tempo so I I don't see why white
shouldn't be happy
here and the C4 square is definitely
white well let's see what Alejandra has
to say about this T of events where
Black's playing unusual variation in the
qga absolutely well actually this
variation brings back a very painful
memory for me as I was white in this
side against uh azaro Grand Master Serge
azaro from Russia in a game that I had
to win to qualify for uh the top four in
the millionaire chess open in the
inaugural uh year and well I ended up
losing with the white pieces as zarov
went off to the tiebreak I think he
didn't quite make it to the top four but
he still was in a much better position
in the tournament than I was and I was
unfamiliar at that point with this
variation I also thought it was very
strange as you mentioned to just give up
the C4 Square to not allow uh the Knight
to come to C3 but i' never put it on C3
I could just maneuver it to B3 but
actually it's not so simple for white to
prove an advantage in this point Black's
plan is very simple he's going to put a
bishop on B7 he's going to put a knight
on D7 he's going to break with C5 and
it's not so clear how White's going to
make a lot of progress normally here at
some point white has to Castle play uh
the queen to E2 The Rook to D1 and hope
to push E4 but white just doesn't have
enough time to do everything that he
wants to do usually if white wants to
get some kind of Advantage he actually
has to sacrifice a pawn he either
sacrifices a Pawn on D4 or E4 by
breaking through in the center trying to
exploit the fact that he has more time
to develop this comes as a very sharp
option if he doesn't take this option
usually black equalizes very comfortably
it seems to me just by the amount of
time that the players have taken the
Checker is not familiar with the
variation it's hard to come up in the
game with this kind of Pawn sacrifices
and ostrovski with probably better
preparation finds himself in a
comfortable position from the opening
thank you Alejandro so we can say
another check mark for an opening with
lots of potential
for um an a very strong aggression
especially if a pawn sacrifice is going
to be uh tried in that in that position
yeah and we see niiko cze up there like
think oh he must have hurt me yeah
looking at the camera and feeling quite
comfortable um yeah waiting to see what
he's going to answer uh to asos's very
aggressive approach of the uh Queen
that's funny I always thought I was good
luck until until I met Nico so my first
US Championship was in 1994 in Key West
and the winner was Boris gulko and
either the previous or the next year one
of the tournaments was very bad for him
and the other one he came in clear last
my next us Championship was 1999 and
guess who won Boris gko the year before
and the year after not good tournaments
for him and I thought okay I'm really
good luck for Boris gko whenever I play
the US Championship he wins well Niko
cze is sort of the opposite Nik is
having great tournaments all the time
he's very young he's over 2400 at the
age of 134 he's beating everybody and
then when I'm I'm just at the tournament
not even playing and I'm there that he
just does terribly and so twice I've
been to tournaments where he's had
really bad results so I'm hoping I'm not
the bad luck charm for niiko CA so we'll
probably find out pretty early this
tournament if maybe maybe I'm far enough
away in the basement here so that two
floors away maybe he's still okay and
that explains another thing I saw them
buying a fodo doll of yours yesterday
now I understand why you bought that was
what it was right exactly good reason
but yeah this is a very long thing so
early in the game and this is what I
expected more from like a Wonder because
if he didn't expect what bodc is doing
you you have a think you're like okay
what what do I know what don't I know
why is he doing this and this is what
Nico is doing now he realizes like this
isn't what he prepared for this is an
unusual line and trying to figure out
what the right plan is and that's what
you generally do when you're and
somebody who's pretty guilty of this of
having these huge really long things is
Anish giri we've seen him when the when
his preparation is over think sometimes
for an hour and just a position where
there's not really any tactics but I
don't know this position so what do I do
what's the right plan I'm going to think
about it forever until I figure it out
and make a uh draw a draw exactly that's
right very well said all right have we
covered the whole field or do we have
one more game I think there's one more
game uh no we there's not we did
everything we did everything okay so
let's go back to our featured game and
see what has changed if anything this
close toyan we'll go back to after
Bishop E3 and a lot of times what I'm
black in the closest s the most common
line is putting his King Knight on E7
and playing E6 Knight E7 right but
instead Jeffrey just played Knight F6
which is also fine and this is actually
very funny I hope I hope my student is
watching in in Charlotte because I had a
lesson last night and a lot of the
lesson was explaining in Sicilians and
Kings Indians black wants to play Knight
G4 often hitting the bishop on E3 and
we're seeing white play F3 or H3 in
certain variations and actually he had a
Kings Indian where he played Knight G4
attacking the bishop and every game ever
played ever was Bishop to G5 but his
opponent played H3 and just let him take
the bishop on E3 he was very surprised
oppon was puzzle right we didn't see
this in this game in this game ruang Le
is like no you're not playing Knight to
G4 so he played the move H3 stuned yeah
and now we see this Rook on A8 on the
same diagonal as the bishop on G2 and
often black can get in trouble there if
he's advancing on the queen side so very
standard kind of move in the close Toc
silan Rook to B8 yes very so black then
only wants to play in the future B5 B4
but just doesn't want his Rook on this
diagonal with the bishop on G2 right F4
very standard move in close Sicilians
Knight to D4 and now instead of moving
the king Knights either F3 or E2 he
played the other Knight to E2 probably
hoping later to play the move C3 and
kick out the Knight and also take the
sting out of B5 B4 right I thought I
used to play King the the the closest s
many years ago I thought that you wait
with Knight D4 until
however you don't have a knight on F6 in
that variation because the bishop on G7
is still in touch with it true so I
guess that he's doing it before the
Knight comes to E2 but that like you
said that enables the other Knight there
are some lines where Knight C2 is really
annoying because again C3 is coming and
uh White is advancing in the center very
quickly so in this position Jeffrey
played the move Knight to D7 so I'm used
to seeing the Knight going to E7 then
maybe later to to C6 but here he's
playing Knight to D7 and he's unleashing
his Bishop on G7 and well this is a
pretty unusual position I think for the
close toan right definitely and I'm
assuming that C3 has been played yeah
they made it they've they've made a
couple moves C3
knight2 yep and rang is considering
which way they recapture oh okay so it's
between Queen takes and the Knight will
go to its natural place on F3 and I have
to say like personally i' I'd rather
have white here I think uh this Knight
waiting within Knight on G1 and Knight
D4 was played pretty early now we have
this C3 idea right exactly and and if
White captures with the Knight then he
perhaps he continuing the stunard G4
Knight G3 later on with castles and
pushing his pawns forward yeah he has
more than one plan he can play on the
king side or he can forget about the
king side and just have a big center
with D4 right it looks like white is a
very comfortable easy game but I think
that black is going to act very quickly
with B5 B4 MH uh after E Capture I'm
expecting not to Castle but rather go B5
with the instant B4 with the idea of B4
and I wonder how that's going to happen
so if you take with a queen then C3 is a
bit loose
so like Queen take let's say queen takes
E2 B5 let's take a look and we make
those movesen E2 B5 Knight F3 B4 yeah
yeah the idea taken with the queen of
course is ruang decided I want my knight
on F3 not on E2 exactly and then but but
his but his C3 week
right okay black obviously has
counterplay here right and the question
is can you play do you have time to play
D4 it's going to be captures with check
on A5 and quick opening of The Rook on
the B5 could also play C4 and try to
block up the queen Queen side cuz the
queen is defending B2 and then we could
play on the king side again your other
play on G4 and so lot of Jor chess big
exactly exactly what we want to see
yes so okay we'll anticipate and see
what uh what how ruang is going to
recapture on E2 and what one he's going
to go for okay and let's have a look at
the the grunfeld that we're looking at
between Luke Harman V and Kad and tro
because they made a lot of moves and I
think there's a theoretical moves this
is the last position we saw with Knight
C6 and as predicted white castled long
yes Queen D6 was played and I know this
is a really Top Line King B1 following
my very famous rule always play King B1
always play King B1 it's really hard for
black to do that yeah although you know
the famous game where uh let's see
gashimov grishuk is that the game I'm
thinking of where the king all the way
to maybe the king did go to B1 it got
pretty far down the board yeah okay Rook
to d8 putting pressure on D4 and Knight
to B5 attacking the
queen queen moves D5 and the move A6 so
wow we got some really sharp chests
pretty early on right and I'm curious if
this is still Theory and I see that hon
velti moved maybe we'll go to Alejandro
to get some insight about the evolution
of this specific variation Alejandra
what do you
think well this is actually a very
theoretical position in a slightly
different move order but we have some
top names playing this with both sides
Fabian Karana the raining US champion is
a practitioner of this variation for the
black side and we have a couple of games
by him he's always chosen to move A6 in
this position and here uh the main move
is Knight C3 this I believe what uh Luke
Haron chose yes yes okay so Knight C3
was played and now here black has a
couple of choices um they actually lead
to very different positions uh Kara's
choice in 2012 against aronian was to
move the queen back to E8 forcing a pin
down the defile there therefore
protecting the Knight on C6 this is one
of the ways of playing here usually the
White Queen Retreats either to C1 or to
E1 to again attack Knight on E5 but
instead of the move Queen to E8 he can
also just immediately put the Knight on
A5 threatening Knight to C4 this is a
very sharp position a lot of grandmas
top level Grandmaster games have been
played in this position with very mixed
results wide win sometimes there are a
few draws black actually wins a lot of
games uh it's a very sharp position and
the reason is very simple
white has in many cases A Simple Plan of
playing H4 H5 trading on G6 and
checkmating black on the king side so
black has to act before this happens the
idea of Knight A5 for example is to put
the Knight on C4 trade off some of the
powerful white pieces normally in end
games white is not in a very good shape
because his Pawn structure is already
very compromised it can very easily be
broken with a move like E6 like F5 like
C6 therefore we have a double-edged
position in which White is not so
interested in development his King side
notice that he hasn't actually moved any
of these pieces and he might not for a
while he's just interested in attacking
on the king side very very quickly I
think one of the most impressive games
I've seen in this variation was the game
leea with the black pieces playing
against world champion Magnus Carlson in
the Qatar open of 2015 a brilliant game
where black was just a couple of Tempe
away from Chuck meting his opponent and
that was enough for Magnus Carlson to
finish off the game on the king side
definitely a very exciting start still
theoretical and we know that kadan
trough is a theory machine he always
knows his theory very very well so I
expect him that he is just deciding
between two variations that he knows
very well maybe with the novelty in mind
worry of but Luke har Vel somebody
that's also very studious has in mind in
this position thank you Alejandro and
again this comes as music to our ears
because we indeed want to have those
sharp openings those wild variations
where um a decisive result is more
likely than a draw and uh developing
your pieces that's P yeah exactly that
that's old F why your pieces when you
can checkm to your opponent exactly
actually one of the variations Alejandro
gave is exactly what happened tro did
play Queen E8 and then Queen C1 as he
was saying has been played before and um
both players are looking away like
they're trying to remember their
preparation or you know and I I like the
way Luke Luke looks like he's crying but
I think it's tears of joy I think this
is his preparation playing after
thinking a long time about castling now
playing quickly remembering the line
that he looked that and that's that's a
very unusual pose there right he was
yawning a little bit before I think that
he's uh I think he's playing the
nonchalant a little bit to his opponent
and then uh and and Kaden also was was
kind of playing the aloof he had the
alof look a second ago where looking uh
straight B away from his opponent so
there this is again a little bit of
Shadow Boxing and uh I think the way the
game is progressing is very promising
for us and let's take a look at the a
Wonder game and see what has changed
there if anything at
all that was see we had castles after
Queen E2 and he did play Rook E1
Alejandro was saying Rook E1 was the
common move and he played Queen E2 and
Rook e one uhhuh so he's definitely
maximizing his potential on the E file
and is this where we are now yeah and it
looks like a Wonder a Wonder took a
while on Rook e one right and now it's
Michael turn to uh sink into the thing
and uh see what's going I'm assuming
that e takes D5 and queen takes E7 is on
the agenda right or that seems like a
fact does yeah and he has to it's not I
don't see it's not quickly trivial to
see how he's going to treat that is he
going to place a rook behind the pawn or
is he going to push it once or then
starts burying his bishop and I'm
guessing that Alejandra has an opinion
yeah let's see what aleandro has to
say guys this is a very key moment in
the game here for black I wonder as you
just mentioned has this thread down the
E file on this Pawn on E7 and here it's
you could say well I could defend defend
my Pawn with Rook E8 and just remain
passive but it is uncomfortable on the
long run uh instead of that he has the
choice of going immediately for the
break E5 a very risky approach he would
be just blowing up the center without
any kind of development but the only way
to exploit this would be by giving black
the entire Center actually this is
probably the only way that white could
try to exploit this uh is by immediately
putting this Rook on D1 and it's this
key move Rook E1 to D1 that the
computerss are giving as the only way to
play for white if he wants to play for
an advantage actually white is already
worse in this position because of the
strong central Pawns in uh E5 and D5
without the move Rook D1 the move Rook
D1 is very strong because you will
follow over with Bishop C4 exploiting
the weakness on the D5 Square which is
much less protected than the E5 Pawn
however it is very unnatural when you're
considering the position from back here
notice that white has just put the Rook
on E1 then means said he wasted a temp
of putting the Rook on an open file you
don't immediately think that he's going
to move it yet again in the next move
attacking the center from a different
angle Michael bodic might be tempted to
play the move E5 which would be a
mistake because of this nice idea of
trading everything on the on the center
and then putting the Rook on D1 a little
bit of natural but very strong for white
very interesting Alejandro and indeed
this is like a concept of hanging Center
pawns and uh those pawns have the
tendency to uh advance and cause lots of
trouble especially when so many white
pieces are in the way but on the other
hand a move like Rook to D1 using
tactics and pins and the fact that the
Rook is opposite the queen to completely
uh to prove the weakness of the pawn
it's funny this this gave me two
thoughts when I saw this Rook E1 to D1
idea when he played Queen E2 I was
thinking of the R Lopez where White's
always playing Rook E1 but you can also
play Queen E2 r d you could do that but
it gave me some bad memories too when
you're as old as I am you think about
all the games that you've played and
you're like uh oh that reminds me of
this game and many years ago ago I would
say about 25 years ago I was playing
frie on neore The Grandmaster from
Holland who was an IM at the time and he
was black against me and he played C6 D5
F6 E5 just like this could happen in
this game similar position and he just
rolled me over I had I had nothing his
Pawn just came down and I had to resign
it was very quick game and I thought wow
did I get crushed that was just terrible
and after the game he says yeah I think
that was premature what I I think you
could have punished me you know what he
did and I was like wow I didn't see I
just got totally crushed this is funny
that Alejandro says it's good for black
unless white finds the move Rook D1
which would be hard for either player to
see especially bodc now you know before
all the trades and everything and you're
not looking at the move Rook e to D1
after your opponents play Rook e one
exactly it's very it's very
counterintuitive and again but this is
something that kind of typifies I think
young players is to think out of the box
and not be impressed just by the stun
that don't move the same piece twice but
rather what is the position calling for
right now and another thing that's
calling us right now is Alejandro who is
very anxious about something tell us
Alejandro well one other thing about the
US Junior and juniors overall that are
the top of the world in chess is that
they're very creative especially when it
comes to the opening they're not easily
impressed by the top level Chas they say
well I have my own engines I have my own
way of looking at chess and here we have
Kaden Tru with a very interesting
approach maybe he made it up over the
board maybe it's part of his preparation
I guess we'll have to ask him after the
game instead of putting the Knight on A5
which has been played many many times
including in a Blitz game between hikaro
Nakamura and Wesley so here at the St
Louis chess club in the ultimate Blitz
challenge which has been played by
everybody everybody has always play
Knight A5 in this position Kaden tro
comes up with a novelty and he puts the
Knight on A7 a completely different
approach not trying to put the Knight on
C4 to harass the bishop on E3 instead
right now he wants to put the Knight on
B5 for example after the move H4 which
looks very natural here trying to
exploit the H file Knight B5 would would
be the followup the idea is that this
Knight on C3 is under attack if you
trade on B5 now watch out because after
a takes B5 The Rook on A8 is suddenly
very active there's danger to the King
on the queen side a very active position
this is entirely playable for white but
would require a lot of Courage notice
how this Rook could easily be joined by
the queen on A4 once the pawn pushes to
B4 who would be checkmating first would
be the question of the game Knight A7 a
very cool move it is a known idea in the
structure but in this particular
position it is a novelty thank you for
this Insight Alejandro and again uh if
we can continue on our own analysis
board this just for one one more second
uh to go Knight B5 uh okay it's right to
move so let's say H4 of course yeah
Knight B5 and and and again I'm not
going to take a takes which of course is
not recommended let's continue the
bishop takes B6 Pawn takes B6 and it's
and it's amazing pawns are three times
as good exactly and of course many
beginners and maybe uh students that
that club players that they're just
making the first step steps at at CH
might look at it and say oh this stands
against everything that we have learned
Pawn structure is so important it's the
foundation of your structure but again
goes to show how in games open lines and
diagonals and King safety are so much
more important than that this will be
positional capitulation by white right
yeah this is actually my chest L yester
I was talking about earlier I was
telling my student that kov was
complaining to me once Gregory kaidanov
the Grand Master from Kentucky he said
when I go to chess camps people talk
about their Pawn structure of an
isolated Pawn double pawns and they
start crying he says peace activity they
don't care about that he was like that's
it's so much more important how active
your pieces are and the immediate
threats that maybe a temporary Pawn
structure snafu obviously here uh White
has all of his pieces on the first rank
black has the two Bishops black has an
open aine to the king Black's Bishop on
G7 is fantastic so for peace play and
for Bishops and for development Black's
doing great and okay he has triple pawns
but it's probably not going to go to an
end game where the pawns are going to be
weak probably not going to happenly I
was waiting for you to finish to say
that the only end game is going to be
when white topples is King over after
being M or close to being made it so if
you think oh in an end game I'm going to
suffer with my Pawn structure and he's
going to be able to pick up my pawns
like Pac-Man no there's not going to be
an ending the way the the white king
looks right now and in just any player
at any level can just optically look at
the black king and see how safe it is
behind the Fortress look at the white
king and sense the danger on the a file
and with the two very agile Bishops
especially the the one with no
counterpart on G7 a true dragon fire
breathing bishop and see that this is
not going to end up well this could be
more bad memories I guess I lost a lot
of chess games in my career I was
playing Demetri gerovich when I was
maybe 14 or 15 years old and he was much
higher rated player and I was black and
a Queen's Gambit declined and I remember
playing A6 Knight A7 Knight B5 with some
Sim there there wasn't a castling on the
queen side just to activate my position
and it was okay but the final result I I
forgot uhuh okay uh won't remind you
okay okay so yeah we're waiting to see
how uh and this is what I expect to see
in the game is when a new move is played
or opponent doesn't know the move Knight
A7 yeah now we're going to see a big
thing from Luke right especially in
position with casting on opposite sides
I think that uh timing is everything we
saw that already material we know is not
not the first priority uh structure is
definitely not the first priority timing
and who's going to hit first is the
priority and he's doing a combination I
think of evaluation and calculation to
see how to how to how to be ready for
that move Knight B5 he has to be
prepared for that move um and he has to
see to see how you going to do it is he
going to play a put a knight on E2 and
just passively defend his Knight on B5
on C3 maintaining the status quo and
hoping to continue with Pawn Mobility on
the king side but then his Bishop on F1
is buried forever or is he going to have
another approach maybe developing the
bishop and after Knight B5 then putting
the Knight on E2 that's going to cost
him time and again it's questionable if
his pieces are on best squares so uh he
has to contemplate all that while he
does that let's continue our visit to
other
games yeah let's have a look at at Cha's
game again and the Queen's game but
accepted okay that seems very
interesting okay so after Bishop to B so
he castled after a really long think so
White Castle just a natural move Bishop
went to D7 where it always goes Knight B
to D2 now that C3 is no longer available
right Bishop E7 and now the I guess
mildly aggressive Knight to
E5 interesting
maybe the other Knight's going to go to
F3 instead of to B3 he has a choice now
but if he does that I think that it's
going to be the slav the the regular
slav old problem with the bishop on C1
and the pawn structure E3 D4 how is that
Bishop on C1 and The Rook on A1 going to
ever get into the game maybe he has more
violent ideas like F4 F5 right exactly
Junior kind of idea exactly that will be
that'll be less surprising I think and
uh I was also thinking about ideas of
trying to get F3 E4 but he needs to
support the D4 Pawn somehow yeah so can
is it possible is it completely
farfetched to play something like F3 put
the White Knight on B3 from D2 and then
try to play E4 is that been maybe
another a long time very long time I
don't think black is going to sit maybe
it's worth it but yeah it does take a
while so yeah I think a good opening
choice for musovski like taking ni out
of his preparation and making the game
very interesting at the beginning but
not something where it's clear the white
has any advantage exactly also very much
to the style of asosi who loves those
kind of wild
positions
all right so um let's look at our
reigning champion and see how he's doing
okay shot Shandra this was a after the
move A5 I don't think Alejandra was a
big fan of the move A3 which seems to
weaken the white squares of the queen
side a bit of course and gives black
sort of a good BOGO Indian right it
became like a boo Indian with the
insertion of A5 A3 where after A5 you
almost never play A3 in that position
because of that fear of A4 right so
Knight C3 castles and instead of playing
for Fe cing the bishop on G2 he played
the move E3 okay black played D6 to play
the move E5 Knight F3 Queen E7 still
going to play E5 pushing for it Bishop
E2 and E5 exactly and of course that's
the white Bishop is going for that more
compromised spot on E2 rather than D3
because E5 is Unstoppable and then you
don't want to start facing E4 coming and
embarrassing your pieces so a very um
how do you say standard-ish position
from abogo black managed to execute the
the E5 break and releases Bishop from C8
the notorious black sheep of the family
so to speak uh White has still Ambitions
of pushing the queen side but he has to
be careful about the timing uh at one
time black might a be able to go A4 and
even Bishop D7 to defend it if need be
and like Al Alejandro mentioned before
it could freeze the whole Queen side if
that happens he has very little to hope
for while black has all kinds of
aspirations in the center and the King
side yeah this seems like back is is
just fine yeah black looks yeah black
looks like he's completely happy here
okay so our next
game uh we don't have any moves in this
game and okay this game the the the
matchup of the day he did he did
recapture on E2 with the Knight okay uh
this is the game rofang Lee wi against
Jeffrey Jong right Knight takes E2 which
I think we expected and black got to
work right away B5 as expected Queen D2
not only protecting B2 and C3 but maybe
later he'll play F5 and Bishop H6 so the
queen probably belongs on D2 and instead
of attacking quickly with B4 Jeffrey
decided to develop his last minor piece
with Bishop to B7 okay both sides
castled and again I wasn't sure which
playing white would would do G4 or D4
maybe he'll do both but he decided I'm a
junior so we're going to play G4 okay
this is the close tocan after all and I
think that's the last move we have so
both sides have developed their pieces
and castled both sides are pushing pawns
and expanding on the wing where they
have more space but this seems a little
more pleasant for white to me just
because it seems like he kicked the
Knight out of D4 pretty quickly and he
didn't really compromise anything
exactly and he is kind of ready to react
um very flexibly like like you said
after B4 he indeed might have the move
C4 at his disposal where he is basically
relinquishing the D4 Square forever but
absent the KN exactly absent that Knight
that usually jumps to D4 that might be a
good decision for white if you don't go
for B4 where are you playing and white
has all kinds of options again the
Knight is most likely heading to G3 and
ideas is like playing G5 and F5 at the
proper moment um I know when the pawn is
on E6 and the Knight is on E7 there's
that saying that as soon as white goes
G4 you go F5 with black I don't think
this is the case here obviously uh but
he has to be ready that is that is to
mean one of the small deficiencies of
putting a knight on F6 that uh White is
able to push it's hard it's hard to play
F5 with your Pawn on E7 you only have a
Pawn on E7 exactly right and you're very
hesitant to play The Pawn on E7
sometimes because because it creates
other weaknesses right so I'm very
curious to see how Jeffrey is going to
handle this position because ruang is
playing pretty quickly he's only use 10
minutes yeah I mean I I often times
judge a position right or wrong by how
many useful moves I see for one side and
here for white I see a ton of moves I'm
I'm not hurting for moves at all as a
matter of fact I I I I can't even wait
to play all of them when I'm black I'm
not sure what my next move is do I want
to touch the E Pawn or not do I want to
REM maneuver my knight what is my Rook
doing on B8 not at the Bish Bish was on
B7 do I want to play B4 and commit the
structure off C4 lots of questions but
many we know very well as as chess
coaches and as former Junior player
myself for some reason this happens very
often uh hopefully for Jeffrey it won't
happen in this event the the highest
ranking Junior players in a lot of
Junior events they don't do well in
junior events we see this a lot in in
junior open and in all these Nationals
we have we see a lot of upsets very
early in the tournament and we see the
Players let's say let's say that the
National High high school championship
we see players R 1800 1900 beating 2122
all the time because they're up and
coming and they're getting better the
rating hasn't reached that and the
people who are 22 2300 they know
everybody's gunning for them their
opponents are underrated they're the
favorites now instead of the usual
underdogs playing higher rated players
and you see everybody wants to be
Jeffrey in this tournament everybody's
gunning for him and he sort of has to
protect he's expected to win the
tournament he's expected to do well
unlike in the US Championship when like
a Jeffrey Je yeah he might do okay who
knows and then he's he's playing the
spoiler here he has to defend his Turf
and it's not easy in this tournament
completely agreed on both points uh it's
very well known and for for years now
that the Scholastics starting from the
state level through the Nationals all
the way to a junior Championship close
championships and including World youth
events that uh it's a breeding ground
for upsets it's very I mean it's often
times that you can find the biggest
upsets there even more I think than in
open tournaments and the second point
that you make is even more more correct
the number one seed especially when it
comes to Scholastic chest there's that
extra ambition to knock him off as his
high pedestal and Jeffrey is definitely
the the person with the most uh if they
each accomplished by far the most
accomplished the highest rated the man
to beat and if we have uh if to speak in
in figura figurative terms if um people
have those uh pictures with Targets on
them in their rooms where they throw
dots on then Jeffrey has the most holes
yeah because for sure he is the one that
people are gotting from they think if I
manage to hold or beat this guy then I'm
I'm I'm I'm I'm coasting every if I
manag against them that anybody else is
going to look like not that they are
paper tigers by any means they are very
strong opponents but if you manage to
overcome Jeffrey the confidence level
just completely yeah and it's hard for
Jeffrey to get up so much for every game
like that because a lot of his opponents
are couple hundred points low rated not
as accomplished not expecting to finish
the tournament in the top two or three
places it's just another opponent to him
but when you're playing Jeffrey now
you're like all right and this was
actually a big thing in the NBA this
year you know when you were playing
Golden State you were like okay if I win
this is a big thing in Golden State just
this is another game so it's very
impressive when you're that good and
you're winning all of your games and
you're expected to do well that you can
maintain that which is very difficult to
do absolutely and I'm really curious uh
if at some point we can go to Alejandro
and ask him what the computer really
thinks about that position from the leru
Fang uh versus um Jeffrey Shan because
again to the human eye from a from a
human point of view we think well it
looks really good for white we see lots
of useful moves for white we see the
plans for black we're not seeing it the
called blooded computer who is a
demonstrative defensive mechanism
machine uh and absolutely unaffected by
emotions uh I wanted to I wonder what
the objective uh computer will say so
can we go to alandro Alandra what do you
think what is the computer saying what
is the evaluation of the computer here
well before we start on that subject I
would say that this is not a very
computer friendly kind of position it is
one of those positions where because the
structure is still so closed uh
sometimes the computer doesn't really
find the correct plans it currently says
uh that the position is completely equal
it prefers the move B4 opening up the
queen side then it says it agrees with
your idea of playing C4 and then it
wants to play this strange move A5 which
I'm not really sure what it accomplishes
it does gain more space on the queen
side but you're not going to be able to
force open that position I don't think
that A5 is very good I do like its other
suggestion of playing E6 uh as a much
better alternative the idea is that you
are going to play F5 as you mentioned
earlier if I'm allowed to now that my
Pawn is on E6 and if white plays F5
himself he has to deal with the fact
that some of the dark squires are now
suddenly very weak and could be an
Avenue for defense for black for example
after the moves Pawn takes F5 Pawn takes
F5 the simple move Queen E7 taking
control over the position on E5 maybe
bringing the Rook to E8 and then
suddenly it's not so clear how white is
going to be making progress on the queen
side yes you have the pawn all the way
to F5 you're never going to get F6 in if
you play Bishop G5 I may even just play
the move F6 sh your Bishop away and not
really be worried about any of the light
Square weaknesses that I create and
otherwise how do you make progress
really in this position it's true white
seems like they have a lot of tempting
moves but suddenly he kind of gets stuck
here the n on E2 is not so great the
diagonal actually on uh D2 h on E3
doesn't want to be traded because if you
ever put the bishop on H6 Black's
happily going to trade this and even
though this looks very threatening you
end up just really weakening all of
these dark squares notice how white is
completely lost on the dark squares
White H black has a lot of domination on
those squares and that strategically
allows him to defend the king side with
a lot of ease I really like the idea of
putting the pawn on B4 forcing C4 I
notice that this week this on the dark
squares in the center is really valuable
and then playing the move E6 the
computer says it's about equal I would
say it's about the same I am more of a
sicilian player than an E4 player so I
always have this bias towards the black
position but I think that Jeffrey is
okay so far he has decided uh to play
the move E6 immediately without playing
before before maybe reserving that for a
future Tempo and I expect here that ruy
Fang will push and move F5 otherwise I'm
not really sure what he's intending to
do
thank you again for this Insight
Alejandra very very interesting so yeah
indeed very interesting to think that B4
with the idea of C4 followed by E6 is
the main recommendation and very logical
one come to think about it again this is
probably the only way to get some sort
of account
plan yeah the position you know for for
a human is White's doing everything that
he wants and the closest San and black
is just sort of waiting around but the
computer doesn't see that white has
anything spectacular happening and
Black's position is pretty solid so it
just thinks everything is okay and
actually reminds me of another story
this one isn't detrimental to me for
once there I'm a bridge player also as
you know and I haven't played in a while
but I remember there was a very good
player in Michigan uh one of the top and
she was playing against one of the best
players in the country in the world and
the guy was saying to us he says yeah
when I when I play her I I can never
beat her and we were we were like you're
one of the best players in the world and
he says yeah because she always beats
herself okay and I was thinking from
jeffy's point of view he might be
thinking okay come on like I'm going to
wait here I'm going to be solid okay and
I think actually this is why ruang lost
in the last round to ban it looked like
he played really aggressively because he
needed to win for GM norm and win the
tournaments and he was pretty confident
he had lost a game I don't remember the
last time he lost a game he didn't lose
a game in Vegas he didn't lose a game in
the world open and he's white he played
Ultra aggressively and in the end I
think he had some weaknesses because of
that and that can happen when you play
when you go too far and I think maybe
that's what Jeffrey is thinking like if
I just play chess with him he plays okay
maybe if I give him a little rope then
he then he can you know make some
weaknesses so far White's playing very
solidly but if if white goes all out
maybe that's not the right strategy he
could be left with weaknesses that he
cannot walk away from exactly very well
very well okay so very exciting game and
again can we see if there's any
developments in other
games we certainly we see in the
meantime we can see Jeffrey Shan in his
full concentration mode and of course
you'll always see almost always see
rufang Lee sitting opposite him doesn't
get up much as we mentioned before and
we are watching you know a long time ago
uh when topof was W was becoming good
and winning all the tournaments in Spain
I hadn't I hadn't seen him this was in
the late 80s and they told me he doesn't
get up from the board ever like during a
game he he doesn't go to the bathroom he
doesn't walk around he sits there like
this I think it's Prett pretty true even
nowadays to the classic if you watch him
in the classic he is almost always
seated he's stuck in full great
concentration and great stable that you
can inred so he he did move his ewn Bak
but not to E5 go back to the analysis
board and take a look yeah so after Rook
E1 we were looking at E5 earlier
Alejandra is saying white could try to
punish that but instead he played E6 ah
so following one of my other rules never
do anything uhhuh talk about doing
nothing but okay it saves the Eon IT
does true enough although I'm looking at
the bishop on C8 and all of a sudden so
happy I'm I'm starting to choke a little
bit on tears because Bishop on G7 Bishop
on c not your two favorite Bishops not
exactly that when you say two Bishops
that's not exactly okay and and a Wonder
did Play Bishop to
E3 developing which is also unusual
blocking your queen and Rook but getting
his last exctly you play Queen E2 Rook
E1 and then put a bishop right in front
of them very interesting setup I mean I
didn't predict this position before the
round I didn't predict the position two
moves ago so I mean E6 and Bishop E3
didn't seem to be like first choices I
thought that he might play Rook E8 to
maintain the possibility of playing E5
at the comfortable moment uh he could
have been tempted to play E5 but like
Alejandro said uh was a little premature
and again Bishop E3 I understand he
cannot play Bishop F4 definitely not
further and not Bishop F4 because of an
E5 probably with a Tempo and then maybe
things would change but Bishop E3 in
front of the queen and the Rook is kind
of
bizarre yeah it's not really easy to
find a good plan for either player no
I'm anticipate Queen B at some point by
black because the pawn on B2 looking is
looking like something that needs to be
attacked but again hard to find a
long-term plan the bishop on C8 where
are you
going well I know what my dad would say
about this position both sides stand
badly yeah NE neither side hasn't really
a good plan or has great peace activity
both sides are worse you know nobody has
traded anything so everything's sort of
blocked up right a big just like a big
traffic jam in yeah very hard to play
for both sides let's go back to the game
we were just looking at because
something happened ruang played F5 so he
decided to go for it indeed yeah he
probably was worried that black would
play F5 and just totally block
everything up I'm I'm having a guess now
that if black is going to play B4 white
is not going to play C4 MH I'm guessing
that he is not going to deny himself a
potential D4 and not just give away
because by playing C4 he gave up E5
forever yeah and if he doesn't touch the
pawn yeah black is going to have his
long range Bishop on G7 maybe he's going
to open the B5 for The Rook maybe even
give better life for the bishop on B7
but D4 is still on the agenda but my
favorite thing about this game so far is
looking at ruang he just played F5 a
very aggressive move and looks super
bored right I like that but and actually
again getting back to my dad he told me
once I really like this player it was a
a visiting player from another country
he was in Michigan for about a year
Zoran gich I think he's a professional
played before yeah and he says he says I
like the way he plays chess he always
looks like he's suffering sits there
like this queen up Queen down he's
sitting there yeah and ruang doesn't
look happy although you would think the
way the opening is gone yeah when you
play a move like F5 you should be seems
like he should be pretty happy yeah when
you play an aggressive move like this
it's like yes I'm going there and he's
CH player suffers yeah
yeah very interesting and Alejandro is
there any any developments as far as
that game
goes well that game will have a lot of
excitement I expect that as you were
mentioning uh if black does play the
move B4 that white will never answer
with move C4 but actually I was taking a
look at this game between a wonder leang
and Michael bodic trying to figure out
some kind of plan for both sides and I
agree with you guys that the move Bishop
E3 seems just so unnatural in that
position I can't really bring myself to
put the bishop in front of both the
queen and the Rook I prefer the move B3
with the idea of just putting the bishop
on A3 maybe the Knight to A4 pushing C4
at some point just slowly expanding on
the queen side that's the kind of player
I am very solid he just kind of slow the
computer though wanted to play the move
H4 taking advantage of the fact that the
bishop can no longer go to the G4 Square
trying to exploit the weaknesses on the
king side and just playing H5 from the
very next move and the computer was
saying that there's already a very
difficult uh position for black he
doesn't really find a good way of
dealing with the pressure on the king
side perhaps I wonder still has this
possibility after putting the bishop on
E3 we see that Michael has put the pawn
on B6 probably with the idea of playing
A5 and trading off this pretty bad
Bishop but again you have the
possibility of playing H4 H5 trying to
make black defend a weakened King site
this could spell trouble for bodc if a
wander decides to go for it it's a
little bit of on the commitment side of
course after H4 there would be no going
back but it's difficult for black to
defend properly against this kind of
threats another point about H4 is hey if
you don't play H4 how are you going to
make progress here on uh White side you
have a little bit more space on the
center but so what what do you do with
this the bishop on E3 is a little bit
awkward he has just played the move Rook
D1 which even though it looks like an
natural move I'm not really sure what
the followup is white is simply
preventing the move E5 forever but if
black doesn't play E5 what is white
going to do to make progress I expect
either to move A5 with the idea of
Bishop A6 to follow up or simply Bishop
B7 to develop the awful Bishop from C8 I
think strategically this a very
complicated position Michael I think has
chosen a good variation for somebody as
tactically adapt as a wander and I think
that he will be finding himself in a
more comfortable position in the more
coming moves now a position that I want
to turn to is the one between uh Luke
Haron velot with the white pieces and
Kaden Tru now after some thought uh Luke
decided to put the Knight on E2 which I
had mentioned earlier it's not a common
idea to develop this piece sometimes you
just go H4 H5 he decided he wanted to
slow down down things a little bit and
after Knight B5 he took a decision that
I didn't quite expect he decided to take
on B5 opening up the a file now Kaden
has the possibility of taking with the
queen which looks horribly unnatural I
expect him to take with the pawn on B5
and now already we have to take care of
some tactics the Knight I expect will
develop to D4 but for example what
happens if I just grab this Pawn on C7
well guys this is almost a little bit I
think like a like a puzzle The Killing
move is Knight takes D5 in this position
now if I recapture for example Pawn
takes D5 Bishop F5 check comes and now
we can see the danger of this a file
being opened of course you cannot go to
C1 because Rook C8 would pin you down on
this front but if you play King to A1
well there's several winning moves but
the easiest is Bishop well actually it's
probably not the easiest but it is
winning is uh Bishop C2 but I think the
more natural one is B4 with the idea of
Queen A4 coming up notice the power of
the Bishops yes white is up a piece but
he's not going to survive this for very
long so taking this Pawn on C7 here
would be a deadly mistake to Knight
takes D5 I expect that Kaden can find
this in his sleep it is a the idea after
all of opening up the a file that you
can join with the bishop on F5 and
notice that this is only possible
because the Knight is on E2 blocking
this Bishop from D3 to defend on this
diagonal in this structure I think the
move Knight E2 was a little bit clumpsy
and pairing it with the very dangerous
idea of opening up the a file he might
just be asking for it I do not know I do
not like how Luke Haron has uh played in
the last couple of moves I think Kaden
already has a little bit of an
initiative thank you very much for this
very exciting Insight Alejandro and I
think that as the games are heating up
and the players are really uh just just
getting ready for really the the big
fight of the day let's take a quick
10-minute break and don't think for a
moment that we're going to leave you
without some brain teasers we're going
to have a first puzzle of the day for
you to solve all our puzzles are
composed based on previous games from
players in the uh junior Championship
and the first one I believe is going to
be an example from Jeffrey shang's game
from the recently finished us
championship in his game against kamsky
so uh please stay with us we're going to
be back in 10 minutes and uh try the
puzzle Mr Mai what's your favorite part
about this
sport I think the strategy how much do
you hate to lose I don't like it at all
what about being second guest I don't
like that either well if I were you I
wouldn't have moved that
Rook
Checkmate sorry whether you've played
chess for years or never before come
experience all the sport has to offer at
the world-renowned chess club and
Scholastics Center of St Louis
[Music]
for
oh
[Music]
you could fly to
Venice or
Paris or even
Copenhagen you could fly all over the
world
but
why when you could just come to St
Louis your trip begins at explor St
lou.com
hello and welcome back to the live
coverage from the 2016 US Junior close
Chess Championship coming to you from
the beautiful chess club and Scholastic
Center of St Louis the capital city of
Chess and last when we left you we have
left you with a puzzle from one of
Jeffrey Shan's recent games against
gakamsky in the recently finished us
Chess Championship 2016 and for the
solution we are going to go directly to
Grand Master Alejandro Ramirez with some
beautiful Insight Alejandro take it well
this was a very important game in the
tournament it was still quite early and
gakamsky came out guns blazing he seemed
like G got a really nice Advantage from
the opening but he let it slip very
resourceful Jeffrey was in this game and
he got to this position G just took this
Pawn on F3 which turned out to be a huge
blunder there's actually two good ways
of punishing uh this position for from a
White's point of view so either one
works you could either play Rook takes
D4 and take advantage of the fact that
after Rook takes D4 you cannot actually
capture this Rook because even though it
seems like there's Checkmate on G2 this
is actually check and you are able to
pick up the Knight on E3 just in time
there is yet another tactic on this
position instead of putting Rook takes
D4 Jeffrey chose a little bit of more
elegant and precise solution instead of
that he decided to take the Knight on E3
with Rook one takes E3 now this seems to
be a blunder because after Pawn takes E3
the pawn is attacking the queen on D2
but there's another important
intermediate check here based on the
weakness of this King on G7 the queen
moved to B two and now after the King
was defended with F6 there was enough
time to take Rook takes d8 and there's
just one more thing you need to
calculate it seems like black has to
counter play E2 with the idea of Queen
F1 Checkmate as well as E1 promoting a
queen with decisive threats but it's
just in time that white has the move
Queen C1 defending against any check
that black has and that was pretty much
all she wrote gakamsky was forced to
resign Jeff's up uh rook and it was just
way too much an important victory for
for the youngster in the US Championship
that catapulted him back then to plus
one he didn't lose a game for a very
long time in that tournament actually he
didn't lose to anybody except for hikaro
Nakamura almost at the end of the event
thank you Alejandra for deciphering the
puzzle for us and uh yeah indeed Jeffrey
had an impressive us championship this
will surprise you you know what I
remember most about that game the most
shocking thing what is it was after the
move Rook takes E3 the solution the what
G did g is always Stone sitting like
this don't know if he's winning losing
or drawing and he turned Nakamura he
turned like a Nakamura he was like I
I've never seen him do that and I've
I've known him for years I've seen him
play hundreds of games I've never seen
him totally lose it like that right he
just couldn't believe what he did right
it was a blunder that's really atypical
of him and he just uh after such a game
when he was pushing the whole that was
amazing yeah right hard now speaking of
Jeffrey uh this game got interesting
pretty quickly nobody traded anything
nothing was happening uh ruang played F5
and sort of looked bored but now uh e
takes F5 was played G takes F5 The Rook
went to E8 which seems a little
dangerous to me because the f file is
going to be open soon with the Rook on
F1 and Bishop H6 the point of Queen D2
and Bishop E3 and this seems well very
dangerous for black I think one of the
reasons Jeffrey played Rook E8 other
than to get on the E file was now after
Bishop H6 if he doesn't want to trade
Bishops he doesn't have to whereas if
the represent f8 then he'd be a pin and
um after Bishop H6 he's he's still
thinking so this is a very double-edged
complicated position I think I think
ruang should be happy with this again
like to the human eye it seems really
really nice because you're already
envisioning the queen coming to the H
file and a capture on G6 and something
happening on F7 and H7 um but of course
this is kind of wishful thinking
something tells me that the computer is
just going to be shaking his hand like
chicken hawk and saying everything is
okay I'm putting my horse on or
something at all exactly yeah and uh
jeffre is having a very long think here
so it's not so simple and for
confirmation over our latest uh
predictions let's go to Alejandro and
see how on or off Mark we have been
Alejandro well you guys are completely
correct the computer just doesn't care
about this attack on the king side it
says this just a bunch of bluff after
the move Bishop H6 it says there's
several ways of dealing with this
pressure you can just move the pawn to
C4 and start your own Counterattack on
the center at attack the pawn on D3
which is the base of this Pawn chain if
this collapses you can start to see how
black would get an interesting
initiative on the center this is one of
the ways of playing but it also says hey
you can just trade off the Bishops you
can just trade off and after Queen takes
H6 put the queen on F6 and again it's
this dark Square control that we were
talking about there is no problem with f
takes G6 because even though there's a
discovery down the file you can simply
take with the queen again the queen in a
very good position the computer says no
problems here but that's not the only
alternative it says well you could just
move the bishop out of the way say I
don't want to trade the Bishops I put my
Rook on E8 in order to not trade Bishop
F6 the computer says it's a perfectly
good move any of these moves says the
computer are just about the same they
give black good chances of Counterattack
notice that C4 would always be on the
air I personally like the move Bishop F6
the most Jeffrey decided that he wanted
to immediately Counterattack with C4 as
we saw he just played the move C4 I
think that uh both sides still have a
lot of chances in this game C4 a more
double-edged move but again the compet
just doesn't think that white has any
sort of edge and a very interesting
moment happened here in the game between
Michael Brown and AXA Chandra we just
left it off after Bishop B2 and black
pushed with E5 counterattacking in the
center it seemed like black was doing
pretty well Michael decided to put the
queen on C2 a very normal move which I
think should have been prevented at some
point I think uh black should have put
the pawn on A4 earlier notice that he
cannot do it anymore more because now
there's enough defense on that position
and he played this move which I thought
was a little bit careless Bishop G4 and
Michael played D takes E5 D takes E5 and
the reason the bishop G4 was careless
was this nice move Knight to G5 now if
black flakes on E2 there will be no
recapture on the E2 Square this is a
very TCT nice tactical motive the Knight
jumps to D5 and notice the coordination
between this Knight on G5 and the Queen
on C2 threatening this mating attack on
H7 the only Defender is the Knight on F6
which now will be distracted from its
job as the Knight is threatening take on
F6 with check but not only that the
Knight is also threading the queen here
would be a completely loosing position
for black aad avoided by that by closing
down the diagonal by playing G6 but G6
was not a move that aad wanted to make
G6 is a little bit weakening it uh he
would would have much rather put the put
on H6 rather than on G6 and I think that
if Michael simply swaps here on G4 I
expect Knight takes G4 to would be the
reply Knight G4 I think this is already
a little bit un Pleasant for rock shot
Knight on D5 will be coming next move
black does have some ideas but for
example if you play F5 already you have
to worry about this Knight coming into
the game the other Knight will go to C5
there's a lot of weaknesses to exploit I
think that if Michael plays Bishop takes
G4 Knight takes G4 and Knight E4 uh
already white is perhaps not clearly
better but definitely slight slly better
a nice little pull here for the white
pieces taking advantage of this very
inacurate move Bishop G4 thank you
alandro and indeed Michael Brown is a
very strong positional player uh I think
that he's already looking at his face
and he's now in the picture he looks
pretty confident he's contemplating his
plan I think he's feeling very
comfortable about his position and
indeed it turns out that Bishop G4 might
have been an over ambitious move that's
pretty careless from oad if he
underestimate a KN G5 because it seems
to me that if my this actually bringing
back a good memory for me in the nimso
Indian with Queen C2 there's a variation
that I play where black really shouldn't
allow Knight G5 and about half of my
opponents do so I like those games and
um you get a big the similar attack on
H7 and also I was telling you earlier
that you know uh some of the players
have good luck or bad luck for me when I
go to the tournaments Michael Brown is
one where when I'm in a tournament
Michael Brown has had two fantastic
tournaments so we'll see if any of these
Trends continue where the players that I
that I see are doing better or worse
than they normally do when I'm not there
but yeah this just seems careless Bishop
G4 like he underestimated this Knight G5
idea because now it seems like black
went from completely fine to like
fighting for equality and probably just
worse right and the two kns uh the white
Knights are looking like they're going
to have a field day in the center and uh
Alejandro do you have another thing to
contribute yeah looks like the grinfeld
game ahuh what happened there this
groomfield game should be about to
explode we have a crazy position on
board here Luke Haron has decided hey
this bishop on G7 is just too powerful
down this diagonal notice how much
pressure it's putting on the queen side
he decides let's trade it off let's just
put the bishop on D4 trade this guy off
after I trade him maybe I can continue
back to my plan H4 H5 but here Kaden Tru
has a very interesting alternative the
computers are saying it's okay but not
necessarily the best move he could just
trade on D4 and play C6 more like
positional chest or he could go for this
crazy move Rook takes D5 the idea of
Rook takes D5 is to open up this
diagonal on the bishop and resource that
we've already analyzed in previous
iterations now any other move for white
that's not capturing The Rook simply
loses a pawn for example Bishop takes G7
Rook takes D1 and I simply capture on G7
next move I'm up a pawn you must take
the rook in order to try to exploit this
but this is where things get absolutely
crazy Bishop F5 comes with check no good
way of deflecting this check but to move
the king away and then of course the
continuation would be Rook takes A2
check King takes A2 it seems like white
is surviving barely after Queen A8 check
again only one move available for white
king B3 and then Queen A4 check and here
it's the Crux of the position after King
C3 the question is what can black
accomplish here it seems like the King
on C3 is about to get M it but it's also
threatening to Simply run away to the
king side with King D2 King E1 the
computers are saying that after Queen A5
check this is simp a draw which is
actually very surprising after the move
King B3 Queen A4 check King C3 and it
seems like there might be more in the
position but the computers are saying no
there are no tactics there is no way to
make more progress here for black this
would lead the game immediately into a
very exciting draw I think Kaden might
be looking for more because his position
has many resources he doesn't have to go
for this Perpetual but a crazy amount of
tactics in the position and Luke Harmon
well if he's allowing this draw he's
doing it so in a very coldblooded way it
does look like his King is in a lot of
danger and he must have calculated it
out and said okay I'm alive I'm
surviving opening maybe didn't go my way
he was surprised by this Knight A7 B5
idea and he says let's just finish the
game off with the draw I'm giving you
the option Kaden are you going to take
it now Alejandra I have a question uh
after Queen A5 check what if white tries
for more and plays the Brazen B4 move
absolutely B4 seems like it would be a
crazy idea the idea of B4 shutting out
the queen allows this move Knight takes
D5 check king must Retreat to D2 Queen
takes B4 check and again blocks down a
humongous amount of material but there's
just no good way of defending the king
because of the absence of this Pawn on
B2 you don't have enough resources to uh
defend everything for example after the
move Knight C3 the bishop on D4 would be
hanging if you put the bishop on C3 then
after after Knight takes C3 you cannot
actually recapture this Knight because
although there's enough defense on C3
suddenly another problem on another
diagonal Bishop H6 comes down and after
King E1 Bishop takes on C1 Rook takes on
C1 materially black is uh not ahead by
much I think there's two Rooks and a
knight for a queen and a bunch of Pawns
but this bunch of Pawns is very very
scary they're rolling down the queen
side very fast and this rook and Bishop
are hardly in the game black would be
completely winning in this position so
B4 too ambitious on this position after
Queen A5 white does have to take the
Perpetual B4 just doesn't work out for
him so uh maybe a resource that Luke
Harman bot was counting on if he didn't
want the draw but it just doesn't work
welcome to 19th century chess my
goodness wow amazing sacrifices I mean
I'm not big fan a big fan of draws but
if a game ends in a draw like this 19th
century chess with 21st century
technology helping exactly yeah it's
incredible the combination is just
lethal yeah um wow so we are really
wondering if he's going to go for that
uh takes D5 that's
really a fall off the chair kind of move
and I'm pretty certain that someone at
Kaden tr's level can see that right you
have to think of R me one of the one of
my favorite games and favorite moves was
VI Kaden tro and the world youth was it
in Slovenia yes when he played these
amazing moves something tactical finish
I showed almost everybody I knew I
couldn't believe saw the tactics all the
way to the end and it was the only way
to play so if anybody can see this
variation it's K and you know he's
thinking a long time he's probably
looking at all the tactics right he's
also questioning whether he he probably
sees that he has no more than a draw and
he's asking himself do I really want to
go to a for a draw it's fancy it's nice
but it gives me only half a point and
you might be thinking you know when when
Yer sitting in this chair he likes to
talk about mikyle tall and how when tall
played these crazy sacrifices he usually
had the drawn hand you have a Perpetual
maybe if the sacrifice isn't working MH
and he may think hm I don't see a win
there but maybe when I get there I'll
find one and if I don't find one okay I
have this draw so then I'm okay so it's
sort of safe and it has an advantage of
maybe I am winning I just can't see it
now and maybe five moves down the line
when I actually get the position oh
there's the easy win which turns out
doesn't exist exactly agreed completely
um and let's see what else has developed
in other games uh we haven't seen a
Wonder in a while can we go to that game
again yeah that was a very unusual game
yes and speaking of unusual so after
Rook AG won and I don't think um we were
big fans of Bishop E3 Rook ad D1 the
computer was suggesting that white
should play for H4 H5 which is very hard
to do when you've played H3 and you're
playing for a solid Center position then
all of a sudden go on the big attack
right Bishop B7 and now I was thinking
but I didn't say it out loud because I
didn't want to get laughed at by
everybody that white might think about
playing Bishop C1 at some point getting
out of the way of the queen and Rook The
Rook on A1 got to the center then maybe
we can play the correct idea of like B3
Bishop A3 or Knight A4 and C4 and so I
was thinking maybe maybe this bishop
goes to C1 and uh okay we we we play
again but instead he did something else
also retreating Knight B1 one of the
favorite moves of Greg shahadi we've
heard an article about Knight B1
exclamation mark So if he writes part
two of his article maybe he could
include this game right and this has
more than one idea white wants to play
C4 mhm okay and the Knight could go to
D2 in fact we could even go to the king
side R Lopez style and play for our H4
H5 again we could also play C3 so that
we bolster up the center more and more I
think the most important thing is a
Wonder's not in a big hurry because it
looks like his opponent's not in a big
hurry so I can maneuver around too and I
have a little better Center my Rooks are
in the center Black's Rooks are are not
so I can I can also take time and
maneuver my Knights around I'm not in a
big hurry right and indeed C4 and 9c3
looked like the most optically cat
eye-catching uh potential continuation
um I would have been really impressed if
he would have played
H4 yeah that's hard to play after you're
not playing that way basically because
when Alejandra said that I wanted to
profess my love to the computer once
again it's it's it's really so amazing
how out of the box the computer are I
mean it's like in a position where you I
have a movie you should see her did you
see it no I haven't but I'm proba
special love for the computer exactly
exactly maybe yeah but but her in this
case is going to be starf seven yeah who
is sexless right you can't tell that
it's a he or a she so I can say it's a
she and you know even better than
stockfish S at some point will be
stockfish eight that's right exactly but
uh always can improve so Knight B1
didn't see that coming no definitely not
and uh and that's why you see bodc not
moving because he didn't see that coming
either that's for sure and in this game
I think there's so many possibilities
even Bishop B7 came as a little bit of a
surprise we thought like Alejandra said
that Bishop A6 is on the agenda yeah
black could play A5 and try to trade off
the Bishops cuz black is sort of cramped
so every trade makes it a little bit
easier and maybe pieces aren't like this
exactly and black maybe said to himself
well the bishop on D3 isn't exactly the
prettiest picture either he's standing
behind his Pawn on e4 even when they get
traded as that G6 Pawn so maybe I'm
going to go C5 and try to explode with
my Bishop on B7 so very very flexible
position it's a crem position the
element of time I don't think plays a
great part here uh they can it's a it's
a maneuvering game they can take their
time and uh I'm really I'm very curious
to see how bodak is going to deal with
C4 because if C4 and Knight C3 are
coming then every move you have to
calculate what happens with the capture
the double capture or single capture and
again the two Bishops on G7 on B7 they
are aiming to become good but right now
they're they're failing to impress
that's right okay so let's continue our
visit around the horn in the meantime we
see a picture of Michael bodak and Awan
deang both play suffering that's what we
like to see yes exactly when I look at
the Wonder with with a hand on his
forehead uh you could just see the smoke
coming from the ears but now you see
somebody's sented to cover it so we can
see it there we go so let's take a look
at the next game who do we have next the
agenda for those of you watching at home
when we see the first 10 moves they're
pretty fast and furious once we get
between moves 10 and 20 it's not as fast
not as fast and is furious because every
move is very important we have to
prevent some things now in this game we
were looking at earlier where I thought
AA got a
little wasn't worried about n G5 as much
as he should with the analysis board on
the main screen so after Knight takes G4
instead of playing the move Knight E4
which Alejandra suggest with the idea of
Knight Knight D5 we do see an H4 H4 was
played a little bit surprising not
putting the knight in the center and
well he stopped the knight from going in
the center by playing the move
C6
and I was thinking if the white knight
was on e4 that black would white would
play C5 and then maybe get the Knight on
D6 but we can't play C5 here and if we
play Knight E4 with the same idea it's
Black's turn to move H4 sort of lost the
tempo exactly and well I thought at some
point in this game if White had played
Knight E4 he would probably Castle King
side but I don't think that anymore not
after they move H4 and now the threats
on the diagonal the B1 H7 diagonal are
sort of met he's changes and put the
queen back on E2 attacking the Knight on
G4 this doesn't seem like the most
accurate way to punish the move Bishop
G4 maybe the game is about equal but
it's a very unusual kind of
position yeah very strange play by white
I really thought that he is going to go
for the natural Knight G4 with the idea
of Knight D5 and yeah because it seemed
like black really wanted to play C6
which he did to prevent Knight D5 right
but that's hard to do if white can get
in C5 Knight D6 right and the whole
white structure okay now it seems like
black is just okay
okay so we're anticipating Knight F6 I
guess
right well we have to do something about
the Knight I don't really like H6 but
we've already seen Knight H6 this
tournament uhuh so okay the Knight would
probably go back to F6 and now W is he
going to continue with his H4 idea and
play some crazy Junior chess G4 H5 or H5
right away is he going to Castle a queen
side because H4 is a very committal move
I'm wondering if you can play H5 right
here now now that now that's Junior
chess and these moves these moves are
being played this is our analysis right
so that's why it's easy to make them
it's easy to play yeah H4 H5 in analysis
but uh we can just take it back but
again again with every game that we're
watching it seems like both players are
suffering just as difficult and one bad
move can ruin 40 good moves absolutely
justess is a very unforgiving game yeah
and oot I think more than any of the
other players in this tournament is pron
getting into time trouble very much so
and well this this time control is
pretty good for him because you get
extra time at move 40 for those of you
who don't know who aren't on the website
looking at the time controls like we did
40 moves in 90 minutes then game in 30
minutes and 30 second increment
throughout the game and I think that
really helps aot in this tournament he's
one of the slower players he gets in
time trouble a lot he's a perfectionist
wants to play the right move and if you
have a 30 second increment and they give
you more time at move 40 that's very
helpful you still have something you
don't play only increments on exactly
and this get really sharp and right now
aad has a little bit more time and we
saw in the US Championship that was
probably the main reason for a lot of
his defeats he was getting into bad time
trouble not once but twice not just the
first time control but in the second and
those players are unforgiving change of
players are tough that's right and and
in previous years it was Ray robson's
main problem I think he overcame it to a
point right it's like I don't think that
in this Championship he was that no and
when I coached him in in the 2011 uh us
the world junior Championship in shenai
that's actually something we talked
about was you can get in time trouble
but every game getting in time trouble
means a you're going to have a lot of
issues and he played a little bit faster
that tournament but again still when he
gets in time trouble he plays fantastic
as does as does oot right in fact OT
missed a winning move in time trouble
against Wesley so that could have turned
the whole tournament around could have
maybe aot would have started winning
maybe Wesley would have finished the
middle of the pack but instead of
playing the winning move he played a
move that was equal or losing time
trouble lost the game and that's how
things went and that can that can really
change the tournament early on somebody
can have a winning position make a one
move BL under and then Fortune's change
exactly
so okay so uh let's go to to Alejandra
for a moment and see what uh he and the
the Beloved cousin the computer are
thinking of that crazy stuff that we are
talking about
Alejandro well let's go back to that
position that you were talking about
here after uh the move Knight G5 and
this weakness with the Knight on G4 you
are mentioning the move Knight F6 it
seems to be perfectly playable the
computer it's a little crazy here with
the black side it says that after H5
well I just kind of ignore it I do my
own thing I just develop and if you take
on G6 take on G6 with the H Pawn which
again it seems crazy to allow this open
H file next to your king obviously White
Castle's uh Queen side it says no
problem King G7 I'm going to contest the
file with Rook h8 computer says there's
no issues here for the black side
actually says uh it's about equal in
this position of course there is also
the possibility of defending the Knight
with the F Pawn even a little bit more
aggressive opening up the king here a
little bit but gaining some space this
would be the more double-edged approach
this is what aad is considering right
now whether he wants to go for a more
double-edged F5 defending uh the Knight
with the pawn expansion or just Retreat
the Knight to F6 as Ben said I really
don't expect the Knight to retreat to H6
because any idea of H5 would gain
considerable strength also I'm not
really sure where the Knight would be
going so I think these are the two uh
possibilities that are being considered
here by akot in the game between uh
Nicholas CA and Alexander oski we had a
few more moves played in the after
castles uh A5 was played by Nicholas
chea which is a very interesting idea it
binds the queen side a little bit
gamston space on this side doesn't allow
black to reinforce this spawn on B4 with
his own Pawn on A5 but it does lose time
and we are talking about how important
it is time for white to try to exploit
uh any kind of opening Advantage after
C5 I think the black has already fully
equalized if white wanted to try
anything he should have pushed a pawn
even further off the board trying to
clamp down on the queen side instead he
played the move Knight F3 and after C
takes D4 he was forced to recapture with
the E Pawn notice that if you take with
the Knight then after Queen C7 you have
this kind of awkward thing thing uh that
you cannot really defend the Knight on
E5 if you retreated the Knight on uh the
bishop on C4 would be hanging if you
push F4 the Knight D7 just reinforces
this threat this will already be even
more pleasant for black than for white
instead of that he took with the uh the
pawn opening up this bishop but he has
an isolating Pawn on D4 this might be a
permanent weakness for the rest of his
game that's going to be a very
interesting position I think that black
is doing okay but thanks to this
expansion with A4 A5 it's not a normal
isolated Pawn position Chan should be
about equal in this position and
speaking about equal well equal in a
crazy way we do see that Kaden trough
has chosen the move Rook takes D5 as his
idea Luke Harmon must take on D5 he must
calculate out that he's not in danger of
losing if he takes the Rook otherwise
he's going to end down just down a pawn
against a very experienced Grandmaster
thank you Alejandro and indeed what a
roller coaster of tournament we have
here and if we have the possibility to
have a camera that is in that playing
role uh to somehow concentrate on the
face of
luk as he just faced that bomb of Rook
takes D5 I would have bet a lot of money
that Kaden didn't play Rook takes D5 I
would have lost a lot that he wouldn't
go for it yeah I didn't think he'd play
Rook takes yeah but you know first round
black pieces it's not the end of the
world but yeah here we go our wish is
their command and look at this wow and
Luke Harmon is looking like hm what what
where did that come from yeah and he is
contemplating it and uh I don't know and
actually this is thing I was I was
talking to my students yesterday when
your opponent plays a surprising move it
was a game that we were looking at the
gut reaction is to sort of move quickly
because like you're surprise and you
don't want to show surprise but when
your opponent plays Rook takes D5 you
don't want to move quickly the top
players whenever they're surprised they
they think forever about what the
implications are absolutely and uh wow
there's a lot of in fact look at this
look wow wow yeah that wasn't that
wasn't happy we have we have a nimzovich
blockading of the look right exactly
yeah even for always defend the others
from even from this angle he doesn't
look very happy right so I think that he
kind of realization is setting in um
with the white pieces in the first run
an ambitious player not a professional
player so of course he always comes to
play I don't think he comes to draw any
of his games here and he might know that
black has at least to draw this
variation with sacrificing another Rook
maybe there's a win so he's like that's
that's not good odds for me in other
words like like play like to say it's
it's another way of playing for two
results when you are on the the the one
result that you want is not counting and
a lot of these situations when you have
where you can either Lose or Draw you're
not sure he might just say okay I'm a
pawn down but it's a doubled Pawn I
better do that but man that D5 Pawn was
pretty important absolutely that's a big
Pawn Yeah if he plays down a pawn I
think that it's that I'm going to put my
money on Kaden for sure and so the
amazing variation that that Alejandra
was showing was the point of The Rook
sacrifice is to get rid of the E4 Pawn
so we open up this diagonal to the King
and then we further Sacrifice by opening
up the file to the king queen A8 check
the only legal move Queen A4 and this
position which both players obviously
see in their head is there a mate is
there a forced win and even if black
doesn't see one as Alejandra pointed out
we have this Perpetual check with Queen
A5 where they repeat the position and
for those of you who are sticklers on
the rules you can repeat three times and
claim a draw before move 30 that's the
only way you can you can't agree to a
draw but if they repeat the position
three times you can claim a draw right
um and it'll be actually very slightly
before move 30 and it's funny even
though black has done a lot of material
you can see White's Rook on H1 and
Bishop on F1 aren't really participating
in the defense of the king and uh well
this would be amazing if this happens
and even if Luke sees this and doesn't
see a forced wind for black he might
just be too afraid to play it and simply
be down a pawn with a really bad
position right and even if he does it's
kind of a demoralizing moment for him
yeah seeing that you know already his
opponent has a draw at hand and who
knows I mean at some point in that in
that maze there might be a move if he's
missing right then he can just be can
just be over right but yeah but Rick
takes D5 I'm I'm glad I'm not playing in
this tournament I've played in this
tournament five times when You Face
moves like that you're like ah I missed
a tactic against a junior player that's
not good right exactly right okay so he
might eventually take enough time
compose himself and find the draw and
realize that it's only a draw and it's
not out of the question that they going
to go down that path uh alternatively he
might be just playing down a pawn that's
a lot more discouraging I think okay
let's take a look at uh another game how
are we doing with our preview match
matchup the yeah they haven't made a lot
of moves or maybe they haven't made oh
they have made they have made one move
after the move C4 which is the last
position that we saw right which was one
of the fine moves that black could play
I think we maybe more were expecting to
save the bishop because he played Rook
E8 so maybe he wanted to play Bishop F6
right but okay Rook E8 also attacks the
E4 pawn and this is an interesting idea
you have a bishop and a rook attacking a
pawn as Alejandra pointed out you attack
the base of the pawn chain so you can
really just destroy White Center and
hope that you don't get mated in the
meantime So speaking of getting mated
ruang Lee is like I I'll Checkmate you
so he played FTS G6 opening up the line
for the Rook since black left the f file
by playing Rook to E8 right and took
back with the hbond taking towards the
center and still controlling a lot of
key squares in its position and well the
players are are are taking their sweet
time because this position is very
complicated White Center is going to
fall apart but material is equal white
still has some attack on the king's side
and of course our computer friend always
says oh yeah it's about equal no problem
and for us it's easy you know when
you're watching chess on the internet
and you have your five computers with
you telling you the evaluations you're a
hero and you're like why are these
players not playing these computer moves
right because some of the variations
which look like Checkmate the computer
out of 40 legal moves finds the one move
that's equal exactly and if you don't
find that when you're playing you're
like oh okay I'm meeting my opponent
then you're wondering why is my opponent
letting him meet me he's 2500 so there's
a lot to think about and in a lot of
positions there's only one move that's
good and if you don't see that move you
could go into the wrong variation so
it's much harder playing the game with
so much pressure being put on you than
when you're sitting at home and you have
all your computers telling you the Right
Moves right and atically when I'm
teaching my students uh to use computers
you especially with young ones you have
to be very very careful because they
treat them as Gods which sometimes they
are of course in some positions they are
Gods but in some positions you really
have especially with young people to
differentiate between uh the human
aspect and the computer aspect for
example sometimes I recommend a certain
mind in game analysis and and they go to
the computer and they come back and tell
me you know you know if you're wrong
about that my computer says this exactly
this this variation you suggested is
actually minus three for me as black but
the computer said had I played this it
would have been minus 7 and I say yes
but in this case y King is going from fa
to B1 having one square every time and
the computer sees it and calculate
everything and if you were wrong you're
going to get mated in the middle of the
board in the out of variation you just
up a bishop for nothing you don't have
to calculate and you would beat Carlson
blindfold now you tell me from a human
point of view which one you prefer and
of course they agree but again it's a
very and you see these Grand Masters
doing that all the time and the the
kibit on internet are like ah he could
have been plus five and now he's plus
3.99 exactly that's not even the
computer's first two or three choices
but the grandm knows but in that ending
with two pawns up in a rook ending he's
going to beat anybody even at 3 in the
morning after a wild night of drinking
while in this position if he sidesteps
something and he makes one
miscalculation it's game over it's
Checkmate or or a big loss of material
simplest way is the best way ex and one
little comment to to make here that uh
C4 not really caring about the trade of
Bishops also has to do with the fact
that absent the C and D pawns and white
unable to play D4 anymore a knight on E5
is going to be accentuated even further
by the trade of the dark sh
Bishops that's so so again there's just
going to be very little for for white to
play when when all the dark squares are
controlled by black pieces um I have a
feeling that that and this is kind of
more of a gut feeling based calculation
I'm sure the computer is not yet
uh crying over White's position but I
have a feeling that that leru Fang is
just Burning Bridges and I have a
feeling that he's going to go all out
and eventually he's going to be left
with uh position in shambles I hope I'm
wrong because I don't want I'm I have no
favorite favorites in this in this
tournament but I'm really really hoping
that that's not the case yeah he's
played very aggressively so far G4 F5
taking on G6 and the question is at one
point he's going to stop and realize
okay let me do damage control a move
like C4 just completely breaks it from
under right completely hits the
foundation and
um I think if black gets a few more
moves it's going to be very very
difficult so I don't know what's what
Alejandra does the do you have anything
to contribute as a computer and or you
are finding something here for us well
as you mentioned this position is very
concrete it comes down to just which
move specifically you're going to play
there's a lot of General considerations
of course but at this point you really
need to consider uh exactly which moves
you're going to play and in which order
here ruy fley really has two choices on
on what he can play he can either take
on G7 first or he can put the queen on
F4 just to attack the pawn on F7 if you
don't attack this Pawn on F7 it doesn't
make sense to have traded off the pawns
on G6 therefore um the more precise way
is to take on G7 first if you do queen
F4 uh immediately then Bishop takes H6
might be a cold blooded move that simply
distracts your queen away from the F7
Square you cannot really take on F7
because after King h8 well there's no
real attack and you just lost his Bishop
on H6 therefore I expect him to take on
G7 first king takes G7 Queen F4 and now
it's another very interesting position
how do you defend this Pawn on F7 as
block let's see there are several ideas
Knight E5 loses instantly to D4 shoing
the Knight away from E5 and therefore F7
is lost you could put the queen on E7
but then there's another interesting
idea here for rank taking advantage of
the fact that the queen is tied to F7
after the move d4 again with the idea of
Knight G3 and a solid structure here for
white uh you have to calculate out what
happens on Bishop takes E4 Bishop takes
E4 Queen takes E4 Queen takes F7 check
now as usual the computers say after
King H6 it's just just a draw this is
very difficult to calculate for a human
being apparently both kings are in
danger of being in a Perpetual so
nothing really much happens uh this
seems to be pretty safe for black but
you could also go for more aggressive
options here for example you could go
for Queen F6 uh immediately challenging
the queens and when the queen Retreats
then put the queen on E5 again
challenging this queen a queen trade
would probably favor the black pieces as
the structure is preferable uh this
could be an idea here for uh White to
play D4 again taking advantage of the
fact that E4 is now defended again
trying to bring the Knight to uh G3
solidifying this position in the center
lastly the craziest line I think after
Queen F4 is to Simply ignore it say I
don't care and just take on D3 with the
pawn exploiting the center and saying
hey you have to kill me or the structure
is just going to be really bad for you
after Queen takes F7 check King H6 it
seems like white doesn't have a killing
blow the Knight will come to E5 to
defend the queen will go to G5 to defend
and it seems like black is slowly taking
over the initiative if uh White isn't
careful white still has a couple of
moves to make threats this would be an
absolutely crazy variation with a king
on H6 very underrot this is probably
what the players are looking at it's a
sharp position and every move is going
to count huge incredible variations
Alejandro thank you for them really
amazing chess uh it's amazing how often
behind the scenes variations are no less
exciting than what you actually see on
the board sometimes even more that's
right and uh he was talking about this
game I I saw that aad Chandra we didn't
talk about at all we were looking at F5
and Knight F6 and saying Knight H6 was
bad and we sort of forgot about H5 which
stops White from playing H5 but it seems
pretty weakening of Black's King and
it's it's funny both Knights are on G4
and G5 both sides have moov their H Pawn
but it's not clear to me where White's
King is going so H5 surprising very
surprising because I think that white is
aiming to put a piece on e4 in order to
fight that you might want to use your F
Pawn that's right now you can G5 you
give up forever exactly yeah so for
example if white for example plays
Knight E4 and then black plays F5 and we
go back to G5 then we can't play f F7
and offer a draw we have F5 and so it's
unusual that if you're thinking about
playing F5 that you would play H5 on the
other hand he may have been very
concerned about white playing H5 when
the computer's like oh yeah don't worry
about that exactly hum are like H5 and
the H files open there's a night on G5
I'm scared exactly when I suggest that
H5 is just as
a a free move in analysis it looked
really scary because giving up the
exchange in case you took it and like
Alejandro said the computer just
coldblooded he said listen I'm not
impressed by H5 I'm going to go Knight
D7 I'm holding but to the human eye and
again optically speaking it looks very
scary and hard to blame that he doesn't
allow that to right and black playing H5
basically stops white from playing H5
forever we don't have to worry about
that anymore both sides have a knight
sort of on the same square so what
should I be worried about yeah that's
what he was thinking and that was a long
think over H5 a moveie we really didn't
talk about very interesting so somewhat
surprising but okay maybe reasonable
anyway and just like a child who is in
pursuit of a candy what what's happening
in the Caden tro game did he play did he
play did he take it he well Kaden took
on D5 and still thinking thinking think
yeah this is a good time to think oh
absolutely you're the last think of the
this is the position yeah yeah could be
the last big think of the g wow that
doesn't look like the happiest person on
know but it looks like it looks like the
if I had to guess I'd say that he saw
the draw and this is what's going to
happen yeah it's not it's not that oh
I'm losing or I'm going to play a PA
down it's more like I think it's going
to be a draw
mhm that shouldn't be super upsetting he
might actually be more upset that he
didn't see Rook takes D5 rather than
yeah exactly yeah drawing trop is not
exactly a disastrous although I don't
think Luke Harman Val came here to draw
his games the oppos big fighting player
yeah I think that year round he doesn't
play that much as probably less than
anybody else fewer games than anyone
else so busy with his uh entrepreneurial
life uh School academics and other
things and uh I think chess is always
second third or fourth hobby of the main
play a lot chest but he really knows how
to suffer yes yeah he really knows how
to look like he's anguished and yeah
well you don't do that often then you
have to maximize it right yeah exactly
you go yeah really looks unhappy and
again what is happening with a Wonder's
game okay let's go to a wonder and
actually they did make some moves I saw
the position actually changed a lot
since we left looked at it after after
Knight to B1 black developed his last
piece and then we saw an explosion in
the center white played the obvious C4
we were expecting expected absolutely
and then we saw the first trade of the
game they traded on e4 okay and black
played the Super aggressive
F5 which generally would weaken E5 quite
a bit but black has a lot of protection
on E5 the bishop retreated and now Queen
is
C7 it's very funny that Knight on C1
it's like how did how did that get there
yeah exactly you think yourself what is
he doing there and uh I'm anticipating
that after Knight to C3 he is going to
hit with E5 is that what's going to
happen yeah I figure he's going to play
either E5 or C5 that's going to be one
of the next few moves although he may
again want to take his rook and put it
somewhere in the center before he does
that but yeah this went from this went
from sort of blocked and not very
interesting to now it's about to open
and about to open on on every side yeah
and the two Bishops that were so dormant
and we didn't know what their future uh
is going to be like is they're now
looking pretty
okay yeah and I'm actually surprised
that a Wonder has a lot more time than
Michael because you'd think Knight B1
and C4 would be but I guess I guess
Michael took a long time about trading
on e4 and playing F5 because it's a big
decision right and I tell my students
when you move your pawns you can't
Retreat them that's that's your final
decision so if he wants to put the pawn
back on F6 he'll have to wait till the
next game I think that was one of the
first acents I I heard as as a beginner
player every move you can you can fix
except for a pawn move for the obvious
reasons Alejandro yeah we have some
craziness that happened in in Michael
Brown's game with h shot Alejandro well
things did explode and one of the
reasons I didn't like the move H5 and
one of the reasons I didn't consider it
it does kind of weaken this this King
side in in a way that F5 doesn't for
example after F5 I have control over the
center and it's more difficult for uh to
exploit this as the white player but
after you play the move H5 this move F3
Knight F6 and a very logical move G4
just going forward on the king side
seems to be very powerful it's going to
be difficult for white uh for black to
find a plan for us for white I'm going
to Castle Queen side I'm going to put my
knight on e4 trade off this defender on
F6 and have real pressure on the side of
the board AA Chandra position is not
that bad yet but I would rather play
with white any day in this position than
have to defend this with the black
pieces I think H5 was definitely an
inaccuracy and I think that Michael
Brown is exploiting it by playing
quickly and in a very powerful
manner this actually reminds me of
something good for me for once I'm
explaining to my students a lot in
opposite side castling and in King's
Indian positions where you know one
side's playing on the king side one
side's playing on the Queen's side if
your opponent's head is always turn the
way where your play is that's good so in
the Kings Indian if you're playing B4
and C5 and your opponent's playing on
the queen side that's good and the
Sicilian when you're black if you're
attacking on the queen side which I'm
doing with black and Sicilian when they
Castle Queen side if they're not playing
H4 H5 but they're playing King B1 and
Knight C1 and B then I'm happy and this
is what this reminds me of we were
complaining very early in the game that
white played a move A3 and after A5 it
seemed positionally very good for black
Black's going get an A4 white can't
expand on the queen side and the whole
game turned around and they're just
playing on the king side now so A5 and
A3 don't seem very important anymore no
the one advantage that black heads like
who cares about that exactly became the
least significant factor in the game
yeah and funny what you just mentioned
before brings a smile to my face because
um you had taught a chess Camp uh that I
that I ran here in St Louis and you sent
the material and of course Shameless as
I am I borrowed some of your positions
to show my students one of the position
that I saw that probably you'll remember
better than the U the audience who's not
not privy to seeing the position but
I'll try to explain it in as simple as
possible uh there's a structure of black
has pawns on C6 B5 and the C5 square is
completely white but black is trying to
push the C Pawn at some moment so white
has a knight on E5 and the most
attractive continu seems to be like
Knight D7 which also attacks a queen on
B6 when it moves the Knight goes to C5
and just anchors itself there pretty and
there's a bishop on B7 to makes thing
even worse for black so every student of
mine have said oh Knight D7 and Knight
C5 right two temp however when you take
a second look at the position on the
other side you have a bishop takes H7
check and after King takes Queen H5 and
queen takes F7 because of Knight on E5
and it's amazing how even experts miss
it because they're so fixated with one
side of the board and that obvious
weakness that you can just see that
physically their eyes are shifting to
the left completely and I tell them what
is the moral of the story look at the
whole board and they immediately agreed
that sounds like a game that I had wi
very possible it was your game I don't
know who the players were I just adopted
the position I remember but I think I
love this elusiveness that that that
that again I don't even know if I would
have gotten it right because it's easy
when you know the solution but when you
look at the position you think to
yourself oh it's very exciting what's
happening on this Wing but there are two
sides where two sides of the board here
again this is so that's very very if
both players are looking at the king
side then you have to like white exactly
White's attacking on the king's side and
black is defending exactly so he
probably was surprised by this F3 G4
because it's a super sharp not really in
the positional mode of the game that we
saw and Michael Brown got really
aggressiv maybe he thought H
positionally I don't like my position
after A3 A5 let's make it tactical
aggressive and interesting and maybe I
can win that way mhm and again I think
we have reached the point where the
players are in the think tank and in
such position we do what we do best and
that is go for a short break again 10
minutes please don't leave us a lot more
exciting chest is promised to come and
this time we're going to be merciful
because so many exciting position exist
no puzzle just keep looking at the games
when we come back we'll talk of all the
developments 10 minutes and we're back
please stay with
us
I'm Mike maeni manager of the Cardinals
and chess fanatic many people don't know
that St Louis has a chess history as
rich as its baseball at the world
renowned chess club and Scholastic
Center of St Louis across from the World
Chess Hall of Fame our goal is to teach
play and promote the sport come to the
central West den and experience all that
chess has to
[Music]
offer
oh
[Music]
I
he
[Music]
m
you
[Music]
a
he
[Music]
oh
and just like that we are back from our
commercials and meanwhile there have
been all kinds of developments uh I'm a
Freedman with grand Masters Ben fold and
RZ coming to you live from the chess gin
Scholastic Center of St Louis and
covering live coverage of the 2016
Junior close Championship uh the most
exciting position that we had on all of
the boards when we left was definitely
the position in Kaden tr's game where he
played the amazing Rook captures
D5 and uh some of you might know that uh
my colleague Ben fold addresses uh Kaden
trough as cading the truth trough for
successes and it looked like what
happened luk couldn't handle the truth
couldn't handle the truth because he
simply believed his opponent did not
take the Rook taking the would have led
to a draw probably with correct play ex
instead he just decided to be a pawn
behind G7 and so he's so he's a pawn
behind exactly and he played the move
Queen C2 exactly and um there's not a
lot of compensation for the pawn in fact
you might even prefer black anyway
because black has an open a file and
white doesn't have an open H file
absolutely and a half a pond to boot
yeah and I'm assuming that uh our
beloved Uncle the computer didn't
approve of that continuation no it
doesn't like White's position at all it
says black is almost plus one if not
more and we're going to go to Alejandra
to see if we are correct in that
assessment the cold blooded computer
said you had to take that Rook otherwise
you're much worse but even if you don't
take the Rook it doesn't like the way
that Luke Haron has handled this
position after he played uh Rook takes
D5 as the I said the computer really
said you have to take that Rook uh he
decided instead to take on
G7 but after Rook takes D1 Queen takes
D1 King takes G7 it says okay things are
bad but they're not terrible just yet
you have this interesting move Knight C3
which is definitely the most challenging
and it's not so easy for black to find a
move you have to play Bishop E6 in order
to defend against this threat on B5 with
your own counter threat on A2 with still
some compensation for the pawn for uh
White notice that there are other moves
that don't work quite as well C6 doesn't
work because of Queen D4 check with a
horrible Fork on uh B6 and G7 the same
happens to B4 simply Queen D4 check
picks up the pawn on B4 since their King
needs to be defended so Knight C3 might
have given a lot of fight here it
wouldn't have been easy for Kaden to
really prove that the pawn is a full
Pawn however after the inous move Knight
Queen C2 now you're really handing black
anything that he wants after the move
simply I think C6 here looks very
logical defending the pawn on B5
defending the pawn on C7 you're going to
follow up with Bishop B6 you're going to
follow up with E5 at some point put the
bishop on E6 Knight on C4 it seems like
Black's position placed itself and he's
up a Pawn on top of that the time
situation Luke Haron only has 25 minutes
in the clock it seems very dire here for
white he has misplayed the position bad
he hasn't reacted well after that Rook
takes def5 must have come as a surprise
for him he didn't take the Rook which
led to a draw now he's in a lot of
problems thank you Alejandro and again
it'll be very responsible of us to uh
omit the very famous Immortal quote by
Grandmaster veteran Grandmaster Roman
Jin Kash who uh coined the term a pawn
up with compensation comp the pawn and
the compensation compensation from uh
Kaden trop's Point definitely one of my
favorite gingi quotes is when you're
really winning more winning than this he
says I'm looking but I can't find a move
that doesn't win yeah exactly that
hasn't happened in this position yet but
this is a really good tactical move Rook
takes D5 I don't mean chess tactics I
mean a psychological tactic three things
can happen your opponent doesn't take
the Rook which is what happened that's
good your opponent takes the rook and
you have a forced win you haven't seen
yet which is also good or the worst
which is the Perpetual check you saw
that's what happens so two out of three
ain't bad that's a bet you take any day
of the yeah and one of them happened and
now he's going to be a pawn up with a
better position and the pawn that he
took that's the pawn I would take the D5
Pawn because this lets the bishop go to
E6 and it's the Crux of White's position
this nice base Advantage when you look
at this position now compared to the
previous position so almost like some
limb was cut off right yeah so just a
really really missing that pawn that's a
real bad Pawn to uh to uh to lose so
yeah we're definitely betting on Kaden
tropy in that position and we think that
Herman valti lost his way in the
complications and now we're going to go
maybe back to our main featured game
yeah that's uh getting very interesting
so we saw we saw trade on G7 again the
game between ruang Lee and Jeff Jeff
Shong and queen F4 threatening the F7
Pawn as mentioned by Alejandro before
possibly the D6 Pawn as well and I'm
dying to see if he took on D3 no he
played the move Queen E7 yeah yeah you
have to be very very cold ploted yeah
ignoring all the pawns hanging is oh my
God but your king is like running around
half dressed and losing the F7 so D4 is
The Logical move and now we thought that
white was attacking on the king's side
but black took over the H this is is
actually an idea in a similar position
we saw we saw an O shot game in one of
the variations where the hfl got open
and black just plays King G7 Rook h8 we
see this all the time and that's what
Jeffrey did the Knight went to G3 and
he's going to double Rooks on the H file
Rook H4 attacking the Queen the queen
retreated and The Rook on ba8 which
hasn't really been doing much this game
goes to ha and who's who's attacking
home that's a fantastic question yeah
and it's funny now that it seems like
black is sort of taking over on the king
side now my computer likes white so I
guess having a king side attack is a is
a Bad Thing funny I mean one thing you
have to say that as long as white
doesn't do anything dramatic here like
push one of the pawns or right now the
bishop is pacified on C on B7 the Knight
on D7 can go to C or E5 and maybe white
can start doing something useful with
his a rock um I don't know if he can
bring it to maybe E1 E3 F3 or do
something else with it but
uh let's get some insight from Alejandro
and
biano guys you mentioned it yourself
what happens when you just focus on one
side of the board you lose perspective
from the rest it's the king side that
you guys are talking about the Rooks
coming in the open file on uh F7
pressure the Bishops are somehow still
on the king side that there's a queen
side guys there's something that you
have to worry about on the other side of
the board how do you reply to
A4 this is the question that Jeffrey
really needs to ask himself uh if Ru
Fang uh is able to find the move A4
which is the computer recommended move
how do you deal with this if you take on
A4 Rook takes A4 Forks the A7 and C4
position that's going to be very
dangerous for him otherwise if you play
A6 well you're allowing this horrible
penetration of The Rook down the a file
both Rook A7 on the seventh and Rook A5
attacking the pawn on B5 are very
powerful moves after A4 you might even
be forced to sacrifice a pawn just say
B4 I need to get this uh Pawn out of the
way so I can keep the queen side closed
but hey C takes B before is a pawn
suddenly black has to prove that there
is enough Initiative for uh the pawn to
be worth it you have to continue with
Knight F6 and now the position gets into
a very double-edged mode A4 is the key
move in this position if ruy fing finds
it it might put Jeffrey under some
pressure force him to find good
resources to compensate being
potentially down upon PA I can only hope
that the student to whom I show your
puzzle isn't watching and laughing at
home that we missed exactly what the
lesson that we that's right I got to
steal this position for my new lesson
always A4 did this is I think this is a
great position to adopt for for a chess
coach when you think everything is about
the king side so what should I do should
I now Advance my a rook and bring it to
the E file should I move my queen away
and prepare a doubling of the Rooks
should I start contemplating how what
pawn to push in the center no like
Alejandra said with the advice of the
uncle A4 and again immediately opening a
new front on the queen side and
immediately you have to favored white
you just have to feel like white is
calling the shots white is having the
threats and U it's one of my favorite
rules but when everybody's playing on
the king side you forget because B5 was
played so long ago exactly so4 has to
come naturally exactly very exciting
it's funny just from this angle it looks
like Ru Fang's head is actually tilted
towards the king side like looking at
the king side over there those Rooks are
ominous on the H file yeah it really is
looking like that
yeah
oh and he must have calculated something
that changed his
mind but those two players are really
quite stoic I mean uh very very very
poker faed players not not very
expressive expressive in their I
remember seeing his game one of his
games in that I mentioned grandmas
tournament recently held here and he
played a rook ending against uh I think
it was Ashwin one of the local Grand
masters of Webster I think yeah Ash J
goes to web for Webster and he made a
mistake in a rook ending yeah he lost
the tempo and as soon as his opponent
responded I mean I could see it
immediately and he he knew it and he the
way he shook this head it was like a
mini headshake like he could see the
tears like saying to himself like his
eye rolling at itself and that was the
most expressive I've ever seen rof fly
uh over the chessboard right so very
very self-restrained now we have like
sort of a busting open of the center in
a wonders game with Michael bodak um
let's go back because uh after the move
Queen C7 this is the last that we saw
when we were analyzing before the break
white played the very natural obvious
Knight C3 and E5 which you suggested was
played and then there was wholesale
trades on E5 they couldn't stop trading
so takes on E5 takes on E5 everybody's
taking on E5 and now that the knight's
on E5 we have this sort of obvious pin
Bishop F4 M threatening the Knight The
Rook on A8 finally got into the game and
defended the Knight mhm and now if black
gets the move C5 in that Bishop on B7
looks pretty good and so a wander said
you're you're not going to play C5 I'm
going to play C5 and try to keep your
Bishop on B7 to Bay the rest of the game
and hope that the pressure on the Knight
on E5 the pin will eventually lead to
something in fact sort of in a double
pin now because probably Queen takes
Rook is also a good move if you move a
knight away so well very interesting
stopping Black from activating the
bishop on B7 the center just blew open
and uh well a very interesting position
where you got to like white a little B
yeah very very exciting position
actually yeah no for sure if black would
have gotten to play C5 it would have
been yeah end of white yeah more than
reasonable because now the white Bishop
on C2 would sort of be dead after C5 now
we have this diagonal on A2 to G8 in
case the bishop wants to change Tack and
we're not really so worried about B
takes C5 and black being a pawn up
because that's a pretty SI very broken
Pawn structure and the bishop on B7 is
still going to be pacified so very all
five games very interesting yes they
they definitely came to play and we're
getting our money's worth that's
exciting and let's go around the horn
let's keep keep troubling what's
happening in Michael Brown's game I'm
curious let's see actually let's see
what Alejandra has to say about this
okay let's go directly to Alejandro
aleandro he has some opinion about
Michael Brown's game yes well this was
an interesting game up to this point uh
we had seen the idea of playing G4
opening up the king side but I think
Michael Brown got carried away here
after the move Knight C4 which I thought
was okay the trade of the knights happen
akad decided I cannot really defend the
pawn on H5 anymore I must trade it but
he said okay the Pawn's going down I'm
also going to get rid of this powerful
knight on e4 and after the trade on C5
we have a very complicated position in
which I favor white a little bit you
have this idea of H5 opening the king
side the first thing I think of in this
position okay why don't I Castle bring
the Rook to the D file make my king a
little bit safer push H5 with more power
uh but Michael decided to play this move
G5 which I'm not very convinced about
out I don't think you needed to prepare
the move H5 I don't think G5 from black
was ever a good way of dealing with this
Pawn as it would just give white a pass
Pawn on this side of the board and after
G5 I'm very curious if AKA just plays
rook d8 and he has played Rook d8
cutting off the King on the D5 you can
no longer legally Castle long what is
your followup on this position if you
play H5 for example E4 comes down the
queen suddenly attacks this Pawn on G5
which you weakened for me this was not a
weak this before The Rook can come down
to D3 and attack the E3 Pawn this looks
like Michael Brown is not developing he
put a Pawn on G5 as a weakness rather
than an attacking Pawn I think turbos
are turning very quickly in this game I
much prefer aot's position I wouldn't
call G5 a blunder but it gets very close
to that very exciting Alejandro inde
yeah it seems like he just didn't play
H5 cuz he thought black would play G5
and stopped the attack so he played G5
first but I mean without without
castling Queen side and tucking the king
away we could play G5 H5 when we wanted
to we need to put our King on B1 and A2
and hide exactly the king's going to be
on E1 for a long time or start running
around the king side that seems very
must have lost the threat of the game
because I would call G5 a blunder after
Rook d8 his King is just terrible now
yeah and anybody would take black now
white has a lot of Pawn weaknesses but I
don't see the mating attack that I
thought he was going to have at some
point yes so this looks quite good for
black very puzzling because Rook ad8
must have been the only move to look at
right yeah because we always had time to
push on the king side if we Castle The
Rook on D1 is really into the game the
king is much safer now my Rook on A1 is
terrible my king on E1 is terrible Rook
ad just stopped castling maybe he maybe
he missed it after the H5 E4 is really
yeah too much to handle no you can see
he doesn't look very happy very very bad
decision to play G5 in that position
yeah one one move as we said earlier can
turn around the game especially up on
move okay so we by the way we we have
the move we expected and hoped in the
game of the day ruley Jeffrey Jang A4
was played so somebody wasn't looking
only on the king side
yeah well probably he was looking does
Rook takes H3 and queen H4 win then we
decided it doesn't okay now I can play
A4 he's probably looking at the king
side to make sure he wasn't getting
crushed and he decided he wasn't and he
played the move A4 and now now we like
Ru Fang's game because uh he has a nice
center right and now he's going to have
an advantage on the queen side and
they're sort of fighting on the king
side yeah opening a new front and two
out of three places it looks like
White's better
yeah so again it looks like Alis could
Rook control the doubling of the Rooks
on the H Val might have been a little
bit illusionary uh from Black's point of
view he's kind of he's hitting a road
block and with the A3 Pawn I don't think
they
sacrificing in the game if we can go
back you know when he played the move C4
he was thinking I'm going to destroy
that white center and what ended up
happening in the current position is
white has this beautiful Center yeah the
best center you could hope for
especially in a close C the PA on C4
rather be on C5 so we could put some
pressure on the center absolutely and
yeah White's not playing for mate
White's just playing a a positional
Advantage now it looks like he has it
yeah he just switched gears and just
went to a completely different different
uh uh way of thinking he's it looks like
he has something on the king side he
just doesn't pursue it he doesn't have
it it's no wonder he's having a good
summer yeah very very he's playing his
understanding is really uncanny really
impressive and now he's looking very
unconcerned
and he's not rushing to get off the T
get up from the table we know he doesn't
do that much but you can see that he's
taking like a mental break from Total
concentration now one of the games
Comfort right one of the games we're
looking at earlier uh where we thought
you know why could have probably had a
draw now he's a pawn down and even being
a pawn down it looks like he's still not
playing the Right Moves he should have
played Knight C3 instead of Queen C2 as
Alejandra pointed out right and blacks
made all the moves that Alejandra was
suggesting seem sort of simple
straightforward C6 saving the Pawn mhm
instead of going to C3 which doesn't
really have any bite anymore he went to
C1 and after the move E5 again suggested
by
Alejandro uh Bishop E2 I mean Black's a
pawn up and I'd rather have Black's
position anyway because of the
possibilities to attack on the queen
side looks like his Knight's better than
White's Knight and I don't see why just
has no compensation for a pawn this just
seems great for black and to boot black
has a nice time Advantage so really good
position for Kaden yeah very very
surprising decision by Haron vti is
really it's kind of really bugging me
that he didn't didn't pursue the uh you
had to have tested Pawn Tex D5 I know
it's scary but I mean you calc you don't
see the mate you have to say listen if I
I'm either declaring defeat
immediately right by by by allowing him
to just play a pawn down or I'm really
testing my opponent and I'm not seeing
the mate he really I'm surprised he just
sort of like a bluff because he sort of
LED himself exactly and he time about it
now what do you think Alejandro is this
uh is pla increasing his Advantage every
move here especially the move that I
want to talk about is the one that Luke
Harmon just played this move Bishop E2
signals to me that there's some
discomfort there's some
psychologically I don't know what to do
kind of mentality going on in White's uh
head right now because the more I look
at Bishop E2 the less I understand it
when you see top level Grand Masters
it's not like they don't make mistakes
they make mistakes all the time but they
recover very well they defend well they
say I'm in a bad position how can I make
the most out of what I have how can I
make it so that it's difficult for my
opponent to win moves like Bishop E2
just don't do anything the M the bishop
on E2 is almost as bad as the one on F1
if you told me okay I'm going to start
pushing on H4 trying to create some
counterplay do something make the win
hard for my opponent then I'm saying
okay Luke Hara is still in it but with
Bishop E2 I'm just kind of wondering
like what what is the point of this move
like where where is the bishop going are
are you going to put the Rook on D1 and
and and then what Black's plan on the
queen side is very clear he's going to
put a queen on E7 Bishop on E6 Queen on
B4 and how is this Rook helping you if
you're forced to be in a passive defense
and down upon eventually you'll see
yourself in a position where you're
doing trades where you're going to be
just down upon PA and any end game is
going to be losing when you're down
material thank you Alejandra for this
Insight indeed hard to disagree one more
time that's right and we have a well to
me I don't know if you and Alejandra are
going to agree we have a very shocking
development in Michael Brown's game
there's a move I didn't think was ever
going to happen he did Castle he castled
the other way actually in passing I was
thinking to myself that he left himself
no choice but to do that yeah he played
because the king can't stay in the
center right he couldn't Castle Queen
Castle the other way so but yeah funny
to play to play H4 G4 G5 F3 okay now
Castle no Castle right and this and I
have a feeling that that this this is
not going to be be approved by the
higher authority no I if I was white I
would push all my pawns backwards now
I'd switch sides and start pushing the
pawns G the idea of G put the pawn on G3
and H2 and put the pawn on C3 and put
the E3 Pawn on F2 and play for a draw
uhhuh well actually the higher authority
says castling was the only way to
survive for sure position oh no no it's
White's busted basically after the move
E4 which is already very natural
bringing the Rook to D3 look at how
beautiful black species will coordinate
The Rook probably has to go to D1 to
prevent Rook D3 and then Queen E5 eyeing
this weakness on G3 the king's are just
too weak B2 is also weak at some point
the computer also wants to say hey I
don't even have to do that I can also
play the move A4 something we wanted to
do from the opening reinforcing the fact
that C4 would be very weak B2 would be
very weak why is just a compilation of
weaknesses in this position it's very
unpleasant to play for white black is
completely in the driver seed in this
major piece end game and well it's up
for black to convert this position
absolutely so from from from King safety
to space advantage or at least countable
worth worthwh space to structurally
speaking uh BL is definitely is better
in all those departments clearly he is
the yeah looks just great for black yeah
he's just having a lot of fun absolutely
I agree that casting might have been the
only way because living the king in the
center is just not a solution but
overall it's just a fail strategy it's
kind of a admit admission of of the
failure of the strategy yeah G5 a very
strange move very very strange I'd be so
happy to Castle queenside and tuck my
king away to saf absolutely once I
played H4 G4 now one game we haven't
looked at a lot which is very
interesting because both sides have
runaway pawns that seem to be stopped is
uh the game that Nicholas Czech is
playing against Alexander arski um so we
left earlier when after the move uh
Bishop to D3 I'm sorry after e takes D4
uh black played Bishop to D5 I probably
realizing that eventually white would
play A6 so Knight C6 doesn't make a lot
of sense cuz your Bishop can get trapped
Bishop to D3 white wants to avoid trades
isolated Pawn position you want to get
some attack with your knight on E5 maybe
the other Knight goes to G5 we're going
to sacrifice on the king side and black
wants to trade pieces and get a nice
solid position these kinds of positions
you can see from like Carol K panov and
from qgs and from semit tares you see
these positions all the time Nimo
Indians and now white still played the
move A6 even though there's no Bishop on
B7 and he's hoping in the end game that
pawn maybe will get strong right Rook C8
taking the open file and um Knight D7
again black wants to trade pieces so
white doesn't have an attack on the king
side and that's what happened they
traded on E5 and now since white played
A4 A5 A6 black decided to play B3 I I
have to admit I've never seen this kind
of yeah and I think it isn't to make the
much stronger I think it's to give
himself the B4 square and maybe later
he'll play Knight to B4 and try to get
the two Bishops or infiltrate on C2 and
I have to say typical isolated Queen
Pawn position if white doesn't get a
Ming attack uh which is I guess what
he's hoping for with his Bishop on D3 is
Knight on E5 it seems unlikely there's a
Ming attack here that I I like Black's
position of course the engine's always
going to say everything's equal because
isolated Pawn's okay and everything's
everything's fine but I think in the
long run as the game goes on if white
doesn't get a monster attack which I
don't foresee I think I'd rather have
black in this position right both the A6
and D4 Pawn can prove to be weak weaken
in and well we're get we're starting to
get into some time trouble situation and
I've noticed in some events that I've
been to that Czech Gets In Time trouble
but here he has a lot more time than his
opponent and I'm not very familiar with
ASR other than here and playing in the
US Junior I haven't seen him play a lot
you may know him better than I do is he
pron getting into time trouble sometimes
not on a regular basis but I remember
even in in one of the US championships
here the Juniors that he played right
there were games that time trouble just
ruined such a good game such a good
position that the I mean we're on move
17 and he has 13 minutes left that's not
a lot that's not a whole lot not for
this position especially and we see uh
cha thinking here after the move B3 yeah
we see no opponent I'm surprised that
dros is so short yeah 13 minutes walk
around have something to drink yeah look
at the other
games very difficult position all five
games could could be decisive they're
very interesting uh and there's there's
some clear favorites in a couple of
games but in some games I actually don't
know who's the favorite still right so
in this game it could go all three
results are possible exactly this is
Junior Chess at the best I think we have
a little unusual move I think in the
game we were just looking at uh instead
of playing E4 he played Rook D6 so
instead of playing for Rook D3 he's just
going to double Rooks on the D file
without playing E4
I guess it's very reasonable because
every position whether we trade Rooks or
don't trade Rooks it seems like it's
just better for black yeah exactly
because some things are just
fundamental R A1 Rook d8 yeah and it's I
think all the endings favor favor Black
much easier to get to the white pawns
than to the black
pawns and we do have a couple of moves
and again confusing alahandra somewhat
instead of white playing for this attack
which seemed like the whole point of the
opening uh Luke Harman L Knight C1
Bishop E2 Rook D1 very calm I'm not I'm
not down upon it's just equal
everything's fine when in fact the
opposite is true exactly and but to
borrow a line from F from um from yaser
he is seizing the defense seizing the
defense that's right seing the defense
so so after Queen E7 he played the move
Rook D1 Bishop E6 and it seems like
black has all the
trums so Alejandro what do you think
about this bishop E2 Rook to D W now I
know you don't like these moves but I'm
going to ask you a tough question what's
White's plan what's he going to do now
oh man that is a tough question I was
just here ready to say this moves are
really bad I have no idea why he's
playing them but uh okay they're not
that bad but the defense here he's
probably just saying I don't have any
real threats on the king side I'm just
going to hold back try to defend my
position consolidate try not to lose any
more material the problem is that even
if he does manage to consolidate he
already is down that pawn and in the
long term he has some really strong
strategical weaknesses for example the
bishop on E6 is better than its
counterpart on E2 that on the long term
is important he has a pressure on A2 in
the long term that's important this Rook
on D1 I mean it looks nice and
everything but it doesn't have any
penetration
squares what is his plan well um I'm not
sure man he's uh he's in time pressure
right now he has some problems with the
diagonal he did play the move B3 already
which again is a reactionary move it's
not a a move that he wants to play he's
just doing it to prevent some threats on
the king side oh sorry on the queen side
and I don't know his position is just
really bad I expect that black will take
a look at his position he'll think which
one is my worst piece notice that the
pawn on B3 has killed this Knight on B6
he'll probably REM maneuver it I would
expect Knight to D7 uh just to put the
Knight on C5 or on F6 somewhere that's
more useful in another uh game he might
even play Knight f8 E6 D4 might be a
possibility in the long run it's just a
very difficult position for white not
only because he has to react to so many
of Black's threats but he doesn't have
any way of creating threats of his own
so clearly black is for choice in the
yeah maybe uh this Knight A7 which is
sort of newish will become popular if
Kaden continues to do well in this game
right mhm seems like he got a very good
position definitely has definitely has I
mean we agree know that it would have
been good enough for a draw mhm but it's
already a success for black right and in
this position we just we are really all
envious of Black's position again it
looks like black has lots of useful
moves lots of productive Maneuvers white
is really hurting his King is clearly
less less happy and less safe than the
black
king okay and how is a Wonder doing what
has changed in that game yeah after the
move C5 which was the last move we
looked at uh bodc got his King off of
this dangerous diagonal which just
recently opened up and he played the
move King
h8 and sort of to probe a little and
increase space so he played the move
Queen three this does several things
will he play Bishop H6 will he play
Queen G3 will he and he's defending his
spot on C5 so taking it is basically out
of the question now um if it works
tactically I I like this move Queen E3
because sort of a creeping move
and Black's not really sure what White's
going to do next although to me Queen G3
looks pretty annoying because if that
piece gets pinned enough and we can put
more pressure on it that's that's not
nice for black and with the time
Advantage this seems like it's it's for
Choice White's really doing well yeah
okay let's take a look let's see what
Alejandro and the uncle have to say
about that well I don't need the
computer for this evaluation white is
definitely better in this position but
the computer is informing me that
Michael bodic has blundered and actually
it's not surprising to me that this move
B5 was was just played on the game it
looks horrible I mean just from a
strategical point of view it is a
terrible move killing that Bishop on C8
I would much rather strategically play B
takes C5 just in order to maybe at some
point push something out of C5 get that
Bishop back into the game it's bad for
the pawn structure yes but it's not over
yet B5 though just goes down pretty much
without a fight after the move Queen G3
I really don't know what he's planning
on doing there's a lot of plans here
Rook E3 and Rook e one as Ben mentioned
simply putting pressure on the A5 Knight
is lethal Rook D6 is a big threat I mean
guys H how am I getting out of this spin
the computer's already thinking I have
to play G5 at at some point in order to
just get out of uh the pressure on E5
and you know that has to be a completely
desperate move Queen G3 seems to be
winning by uh my standards I think after
Queen G3 the game is completely a
wonders the point to play
G5 right well no but D5 is very strange
and I would if my student played that i'
say next move I want you to play B6
right get back to B6 where you belong
it's a very nervous move perhap the he
was rattled by that pin and he's just uh
he's just unable to think clearly of how
to get rid of it wow B5 is really
positionally terrible for B7 the pawn on
C5 is a Monster yeah if White had like
some concerns about a b Tak C at some
point and maybe some now even that is
gone and indeed Queen G3 is really a
natural move I cannot believe that a
wonder will not play yeah I think that's
probably the main reason why he played
Queen E3 yeah but now he doesn't have
defend C5 Pawn anymore so and I really
love the ideas of uh Rook D6 on one
sense you're breaking the PIN for a
moment but you're disconnecting the
Queen's defense on the Knight when the
Knight there moves The Rook is just
going to become completely crazy and
take on G6 for example or reopening the
F4 Bishop attack on a queen on C7 you
know this is usually y's chair and I'm
wondering what he would think about B5
what he would say he would fall it's
such a it won't be his chair for long
it's such an antier move he would be
just totally shocked right it's a
completely anti-position move it's
probably the worst movie we've seen so
far to today really it's even it's even
worse than not taking the Rook on D5
because this is just yeah it's it's like
a recipe for instant suffering the other
game still is going on here you're just
waiting to be head served that's it now
back to our game you know our our key
matchup today uh ruang versus Jeffrey
okay it seems like Jeffrey according to
what Alejandra said earlier took maybe
the best way out which was to not allow
this white Rook to dominate down the a
file and after a very long thought he
played B4 that's not the move that you
want to play play but you don't want
white to play Rook A7 either and you
don't want to lose a Pawn on the Queen's
side but this way at least he may have
some counterplay of course ruang capture
the pawn on B4 and uh well let's go to
Alejandro and see what he and and the
uncle as you call him have to say about
this Pawn sacrifice the game gets crazy
now Jeffrey must justify the fact that
he's down upon Pawn which means that he
must take action now the only way to do
that is to bring more pieces into the
game he must choose between Knight f8
trying to get Knight E6 Knight G5 in
attack here on the uh King side or the
more straightforward and probably better
way of doing this Knight to F6 lots of
tactics to consider notice that E4 is
currently hanging you can also play
Knight H5 to remove some of the
Defenders of the king side also Bishop
C8 with the idea of attacking this very
weak H3 Pawn will be up in the air very
complex position the computer for
example says after Knight F6 you must
play the move Rook E1 if you want to
defend this Pawn you could consider D5
but again after Bishop C8 it seems like
you guys have uh too many problems here
on the H3 Square so the computer
recommends Rook E1 with the idea that
after Bishop C8 you Counterattack you
with your own break on the center E5
comes into play guys the variations
after this come a little bit crazy paon
takes C5 Pawn takes C5 for example
Knight H5 uh trying to create more
threats on the king side Knight takes
would be almost forced Rook 8 takes H5
and you can see there's pressure all
over the board E5 is weak H3 is weak B4
is weak the computer says you can trade
here Queen F6 check takes and after King
H6 again this position on the king
probably the safest H3 is hanging and
it's not obvious how White's going to
make any progress but this is a very
risky variation here for black he has
played the move Knight F6 in this
position and it's up to White to
consider Rook E1 or D5 he can also play
the move E5 immediately if he wants uh
there's a lot of captures on the board
board and a lot of things to consider
for both sides black would have the
option of playing between Knight D5
blocking the diagonal or Knight E8 the
reason that he cannot take on E5 is that
after Bishop takes B7 the queen cannot
capture the bishop because the Knight on
F6 would lack any Defenders so after E5
another uh possibility to consider the
game becomes very very wild very crazy
and this might favor rang maybe not from
an objective point of view maybe the
computer says that black is still okay
and it actually does think that after E5
black is okay with the move Knight D5
but let's consider that Jeffrey only has
11 minutes left to find a series of very
dangerous moves very very exciting we
were praising uh Ru frang Lee and
rightfully so but I guess at some point
we kind of lost track to the fact that
uh Jeffrey sh didn't get his uh High
rating by getting it in a raffle but
rather by uh becoming very very good
yeah I went to that raffle they gave me
nothing you got nothing I get nothing
too yeah but but Jeffrey Shang
definitely uh very calm defending his
position
gaining his counterplay understanding
that by pushing the E4 and H3 pawns he
might get his counterplay and of course
Roofing it's it's a double-sided game
right ruang has still his own uh his own
ruang has more time he's got uh an extra
Pawn at the moment it's a very
complicated position to me it seems more
like a a Ru Fang type of position than a
Jeffrey position but that can change any
any moment right and yeah I mean I just
favor white because white has more time
and an extra Pawn but it's
I'm I'm glad I'm not playing this game
this is really easy to blunder this game
Rook A1 is the move I really want to see
I'm really curious if he'll play it
because I think it's really going to be
exciting Rook A1 with the idea of
E5 yeah our our key match up of the day
isn't disappointing not at all very very
exciting Let's see we don't have a lot
of moves in a lot of games because uh
the players are slowing down a little
bit and
uh well guys it's it's a good time to
actually analyze some variations let's
see what Jeffrey might be thinking about
in this position because let's remember
this move E5 looks very very dangerous
the computer says you have to play
Knight D5 we already explained that D
takes E5 doesn't work because of Bishop
takes B7 clearly you cannot take the
bishop on G2 because e takes F6 check
Forks the king and the queen so you must
move the Knight away let's uh assume you
move it to D5 and here after Pawn takes
D6 Jeffrey has to really consider the
fact that Queen D7 is his only move you
cannot take on D6 again because this
queen has a very important role he has
she has to defend the pawn on F7 and
after Queen D7 if you count the material
White's up two pawns right now and it
doesn't seem like there's enough
compensation computer says everything's
okay Knight on F4 is a big threat in
this position maybe before it's a little
bit weak too you don't want to give up
the bishop because after Bishop takes D5
a lot of threats on the king side so
Jeffrey really playing with fire but he
says everything's okay I'm down a lot of
material but my compensation is there
definitely great play from Jeffrey Shan
in a position that would have otherwise
been quite difficult Rook E1 is
definitely the best move according to
the engines but E5 in my human view is
very very tempting and indeed I think
that that is one thing that
differentiates very strong players from
the Lesser players and again I think
it's true for almost every level that
some people get completely affected by
some Mish happening in the game like
they lost a pawn they had to play before
and it really really affects badly
strong players and especially cool
headed level play levelheaded players
like Jeffrey are completely unimpressed
by it and just correctly evaluating that
they have strong counter Chances with
the initiative even though they're down
one or two points yeah a player in the
tournament who's not as experienced as
Jeffrey not playing a lot is Luke Harman
valadi and it seems like he didn't see
Rook takes D5 exctly his reaction was so
infurious he sort of went into like the
turtle mode like oh this is this is
terrible I lost my D5 Pawn if I take the
Rook it's too dangerous so I'm going to
give me pawn down and try to hold and
that's you can see Jeffrey J's having
the opposite reaction where oh A4 that's
a good move now we have to mess the game
up a little bit and make it more
interesting so I have counter chances
exactly and it's not only the initial
reaction to a surprise Rook D5 in one
game A4 in the other uh but the the the
consequent move moves after that right
Luke Play Bishop B2 Rook D1 and like you
said went into some turtle mode where
Jeffrey just keep finding the best moves
and probably analyzing the variations to
uh to to to his fighting really hard
exactly he's really tough to beat mhm so
we have a trade of Rooks in chandra's
game where we really like Black's
position after Rook D6 we expected E4
and Rook D3 with that idea uh White
traded Rooks Rook D1 they traded on D6
and again whether it's Queen and Rook or
it's a queen ending or Rook ending white
has a lot of weak pawns right and of
course with the Queen's on the board the
king is exposed on G1 so I think white
wants to trade but just so he doesn't
doesn't get in trouble on the king side
but again H4 C4 E3 that's a lot of weak
pawns right much much much easier to get
than F7 and B7 for example E5 so just a
very nice positional uh game for black
and again black maybe can take his time
and play E4 Rook D3 later another idea
is E4 and as Alejandro pointed out Queen
E5 so that we have centralized I think
one he played a move and let's he did
play played Rook
F2 again not not the kind of move that's
going to
not the most exciting move for white
yeah just very defensive see the problem
was even if he wants to trade Rooks he
can't do it here because he'd lose his e
eong with check right and so if he can't
challenge the defile I think he's just
deciding he's GNA protect the second
Rank and unpin the epon and just wait
and hope that he can hold this position
because material is equal but black
really seems to have a big Advantage
here absolutely and the question is how
but after E4 I'm assuming he wants to
play Rook F4
right that's my guess otherwise Rook D3
is just completely destroying that's
right and now would he play would he
play Queen
E5 defending his Pawn keeping pressure
on B2 could also defend it with Rook e
six which the question is can I well
yeah but the question is can I just keep
attacking the point on e4 and yeah I
don't think he's going to play E4
because he didn't play E4 earlier when
probably it was better than it is now
and I think his idea is just to keep his
Advantage I was a bit surprised he took
on D6 with the Rook we not entirely
surprised because but I thought he was
going take with the queen as well and
then then keep some other options
intact yeah it seems like both are good
it just seems really difficult to play
White it's a longsuffering defense yeah
I think black can just play kovan Star
King G7 improve his position there's no
rush the weaknesses are permanent right
no need to do anything drastic or
committal where you
can you can justify it later
Alejandro uh a lot of events have
happened in that game a defitely on the
driver seat but I want to focus a little
bit on the OSI game after uh we left it
off right around actually we haven't
seen it for a while we had this position
where white uh black play B3 with the
idea of getting the Knight to B4 and I
think Nicolas idea of Bishop B5 was
actually quite bad he's underestimating
the power of this Rook coming to C2 OSI
took a very long think which honestly he
shouldn't have done because he doesn't
have that much time we're only on move
18 22 moves away from time control after
Knight takes E5 which was played in the
game uh Nicholas took on E5 pretty
quickly the only move and now the very
powerful idea of Rook C2 might change
things up in this game the queen must go
somewhere but it doesn't have a lot of
good spaces let's say that it goes to G4
for example and now this very nice move
not the only move but one of the very
powerful moves in the position Queen B8
the idea is that yes you could have
taken the pawn on B2 but you let go of
the Pawn on A7 and suddenly we have
these two pawns racing towards the
finish and this case the queen is
attacking the pawn uh the bishop on B5
defending the pawn on A7 and suddenly
it's only black that has a pass Pawn to
his name you could be worried about
something like Bishop H6 but I have the
resource Queen takes E5 defending here
on the G7 square and completely winning
so the bishop must retreat but after
Rook takes B2 it seems like Black's
position is really really powerful white
still has to capture this A7 Pawn if he
wants to make progress for example he
could try to move Queen
D4 but after Rook A2 it seems like black
is simply much much faster for example
if you take on A7 I can capture on E5
notice how this attacks this Rook on A1
there is no chance to take the bishop on
E7 and of course if you trade then the
pawn will be promoting next move this
Pawn on B3 seems to be very very
dangerous and after uh Rook C2 which I
expect of stoski to play it seems like
black is perhaps not completely winning
but very close to doing so very thank
you again for those amazing variations
Alejandro and again not surprising that
black completely took over in this game
and I think again as the games are still
looking very very promising uh again
it's time for us to take our third break
of the day and come back to you with the
further report on developments and those
games please stay with us a lot more
exciting chess is is promised to come by
to come next uh we'll be back in just a
few minutes please stay with
[Music]
us
I'm Mike maeni manager of the Cardinals
in chess fanatic at the world-renowned
chess club and Scholastic Center of St
Louis across from the World Chess Hall
of Fame St Louis status as the chess
capital of the nation is on Full display
with a welcoming environment and
Scholastic outreach program that works
with over a 100 Schools our goal is to
teach play and promote the sport so
whether you've played for years or never
before we invite you to experience all
chess has to
offer
[Music]
for
yeah
[Music]
he
w
[Music]
n
of
you
[Music]
and welcome back once more to the live
coverage of the 2016 US Junior closed
just Championship coming to you coming
to you from the uh chess club and
Scholastic Center of St Louis uh when we
left the games were going into high gear
and sure enough more developments have
happened as a matter of fact we had some
very interesting strategic strategic uh
what we call maybe aggressive retreats
in the game between Liu Fang and Jeffy
Shan and for more on that we're going to
move directly to Grand Master Alejandro
Ramirez Alejandra crazy things have
happened in this game very sharp very
wild here ruang decided to play rookie
one which we consider to be the best
move just before the break and instead
of playing something maybe that I
expected more like Bishop C8 immediately
Jeffrey Shan decided to play the move
Knight to H7 and you're wondering
where's this Knight going well you
suddenly see the Knight goes to G5 and
this pressure on H3 would be
irresistible now this Rooks would come
into the game and the King on G1 would
feel a lot of pressure but R Fang
decided he's going to play E5 a very
strong move you don't have time to take
on G2 in this position because now Pawn
takes D7 The Rook coming to E7 blocks
getting mated on this side of the board
this doesn't work for all at all for
Jeffrey he decided instead to play the
move D5 blocked this side of the board
it kills the bishop but only temporarily
um rufing decided to play Queen E3
opening up this Rook on the file and
pushing for the move E6 he could have
played E6 uh immediately that would have
also been a very interesting idea maybe
even stronger than what he did after
Queen E3 Bishop C8 was a great move with
the idea of putting pressure on the H3
square and again this drops this Pawn on
D5 which R Frank decided to take but
Knight G5 comes in a lot of aggression
here on the side of black he's going to
threaten to take on H3 next move there's
a lot of Danger on the King on G1 white
must be very careful and keep his
position close and compact he has to
find the move Rook F6 and he has found
it Rook F6 cutting the king the Queen
off from the King side in order for this
King on G1 to feel a lot safer again no
choice for the black side there are a
lot of threats on the board including
the weakness on the G5 KN Knight now now
that the queen has been cut off he must
take on H3 with check no choice again
the king must go to F1 the reason it
cannot go to G2 because Bishop B7 and
Bishop returns to this diagonal and if
the trade of Bishop happens this would
be absolutely disastrous for the white
pieces so we are currently in the
position after Rook F6 Knight takes H3
and I see that R Frank has actually
played King G2 which is a blunder he had
to play the move King F1 and after
Bishop B7 I'm not entirely sure how he
figures he's going to keep everything
together for example after Bishop takes
B7 Queen takes B7 his check and you
don't have the time to play Queen F3 you
would just like to transition into an
end game but after I trade take Knight
G5 check King goes for example back to
G2 is very dangerous because of Rook H2
and if you go to E3 then Rook G4 and
this Rook coming down the other H file
this is very dangerous already Bishop B7
would be a huge move giving black the
advantage Jeffrey I believe was in quite
severe time pressure but this move King
G2 was a very strong mistake he had to
play the move King F1 which leaves the
king much less exposed and actually a
more natural move because there are no
Knight F4 check tricks in any kind of
position I don't really quite understand
why he played King G2 quickly Jeffrey
played Bishop B7 and it seems like R
Fang is in a lot of trouble now against
Jeffrey Shong incredible developments
indeed just when it seemed like that uh
he managed to find his way in this Maze
of bedam that the game turned into uh
and I was so impressed by both of them
then sure enough just seem like he got
out they pulled him back in exactly
right that's exactly right no but I mean
Jeffrey really playing well and with
very little time and with a position
that probably wasn't the best and
finding all kinds of good chances good
counter chances and now the time is
about the same uh for the both players
have about eight or nine minutes and to
play this crazy position without
computer assistance that's not
incredible finding all those all those
strong moves I mean to think Bishop C8
and then Bishop takes D5 when the H3
Pawn is so Bishop goes back to B7 those
are just hard moves to see he probably
didn't see Bishop B7 because the bishop
just went to C8 so you're not looking
for a move like that that's probably the
move that he the position just changed
the D5 Pawn went away my heart goes
really out to to ruang to uh to defend
find so many strong moves and then one
little slip and and just is so unfor now
speaking of uh interesting games that
look like they may be over at some point
we got a wonders game and let's go to
Alejandro who uh is going to show us
basically the end of the game is coming
soon Alejandro two games are basically
about to finish but this one the a
Wonder game I think is the one that is
more clear after the pin down on the f
file uh on the on this diagonal and the
E file Bishop F6 was played Rook E3 very
natural move we had talked about this
the idea of pressuring down the uh the E
file Queen G7 Rook E1 was playing play I
mean there was just no stopping this
possibility Queen G7 was actually in an
accurate move he had to play the move G5
which is a desperate attempt to relieve
the pressure after the move Queen G7
Rook E1 B4 which is currently the
position that we have on the board uh
all a Wonder really has to do is move
the Knight he can move it to D1 or A4 it
doesn't really matter and there is just
too much pressure on the Knight you
cannot defend it it's currently under
attack and it's spinned against this
Rook on E8 this is completely lights out
another position that's completely lost
here is a game between Alexander rovski
with black against Nicholas cze we left
it off on this variation a lot of the
things that we had talked about happened
Rook takes B2 happened uh this
inaccurate move Rook A4 G6 was played
and then we got to a variation that was
very similar to what we had considered
on air after Queen D4 the move Rook A2
is very strong the Rooks must be traded
off in this case because the Rook ended
up on A4 which is actually not a very
good move Queen takes A7 was very uh
strong it seems it seems like he creat
create a pass Pawn as well as blacks but
that's not the case because after Queen
takes E5 this Pawn on the a file is
simply queening after Bishop D4 the very
powerful move Queen G5 Queen F4 also
possible but he decided to play Queen G5
instead and after F3 this is the killing
blow sty found it very very quickly he
had more than one but this one is
finisher Bishop takes F3 is a great move
the idea is that here you must retake
with the Rook otherwise you're get made
it on
G2 and after for example A1
Queen
and Bishop takes A1 Bishop C5 check is a
very important move and now suddenly The
Queen Is Lost due to this Fork this
would be just completely lights out for
checka Bishop takes F3 a fantastic move
finishing off the game the idea of
course that you're distracting The Rook
from the A1 square and that's pretty
much all she wrote I think that after
Rook takes a F3 which was played oski
will have no problems finding the
distracting move A1 Queen winning a
queen and pretty much the game thank you
Alejandro and it seems that indeed
winter is coming for both Michael bodak
and Nicholas ccha uh looks like their
opponent really played a pretty
marvelous game right yeah I I've never
seen this kind of uh both sides queening
their a pawn in this kind of opening
both sides just kept pushing their pawns
and I was like well that's for
positional reasons then they both tried
to Cen and it looks like one of those
going to managed to do it yeah and the B
Pawn shifted to the a file and W Bishop
takes F3 is a really great tactic in
time trouble especially absolutely
that's uh an amazing tactic right and
now he is sing and probably going to
find uh I don't think it's that
difficult to find I'm just wondering if
he's looking at playing Bishop C5
immediately he did it yeah so promoted
to a queen A1
Queen it's nice to have two queens yeah
and I think the czechy is really in in a
world of trouble right now yeah as
Alejandro demonstrated in his variations
very very difficult
wow an amazing tactical uh well turn of
events in this game and OSI played
really well in time trouble marvelously
really played so many good moves really
was he going to be in time trouble for
the rest of the game until they they get
to move 40 if if white can make it that
far right but he did a fantastic job
really impressive now let's have a look
at oot gin because it look like it looks
like he was taking over also but I don't
know what's happening now uh we last
looked after the move E4 just yeah white
played F4 and now black found the very
strong idea Rook D3 to double Rooks to
double on The dile Rook takes E4 Queen
D6 not only are we threatening to come
to D1 and D2 and and possibly win this
queen queen G3 is not not such a bad
move either so white has a lot of
trouble here he played the move Queen
F3 Rook D1 check Rook D2 check he got
his Pawn back the pawn that he gave up
on e4 by taking on B2 um now my computer
doesn't like Rook takes B2 as much as uh
I don't know Alejandro has a better
computer than me possibly and after they
move Rook D4 the computer thinks that my
computer Le thinks that white is back
into the game I'm wondering instead of
Rook takes B2 if there was another move
that black could have played to maybe
increase his Advantage I'm thinking of a
move like like Queen H2 but then Rook e
haek is very strong so the computer
really likes black here but then after
Rook takes B2 on my engine at least it's
giving away the advantage but to me
that's a very natural looking move but
it gives away the defile and now black
has to be a little careful Al also
because if we play too much for M then
we can get made it ourselves this
happens very often in Queen and Rook end
games both sides playing for mate the
kings are both exposed now maybe
Alejandra has a point of view uh maybe
the advantage wasn't so much for black
as we thought or was Rook takes B2 a
mistake Alejandro or
E4 Alejandra what do you think this was
definitely a mistake by black he
shouldn't have taken the pawn on B2 he
had several choices I think the most
prze was to Simply put the King on f8
say you don't have any threats as white
I'm going to make my king safer not
allow your Rook to come to the eighth
Rank and then it's a lot of pressure you
can always take on B2 later in the game
as was pointed out that would have been
devastating but I have an update we have
blunders on several boards now first of
all I don't like the way that uh a
wander decided to play this variation he
decided to take on E5 immediately
whereas he could have just retreated the
Knight and then won the Knight on E5
later instead he decided to take and
allow all of this variation with a lot
of complicated traits also it was better
to take with the Rook on this variation
and we by kind of by force we got into
this end game which is completely lost
for Block but still he can hold on for
longer than he should have been allowed
to now for the real blunders we have in
this position a horrific blunder by AB
by Kaden Tru completely dismantling his
Advantage I cannot begin to explain this
move but he did play C4
and after Pawn takes C4 he's thinking
for a long time I think he forgot that
after Pawn takes C4 white simply has the
move Bishop takes C4 and because the D7
Knight is hanging you cannot actually
recapture on C well you can but it's not
very good anymore you allowed the
capture on D7 and just like that with a
huge blunder of C4 B takes C4 black ADV
Vantage has completely evaporated here
white is completely fine well he was
blundered a pawn back usually you have
to work really hard to get that pawn and
Kaden Trove just threw it away in the
game Jeffrey Shan against Len we have
another problem here for white after
Bishop B7 he should have taken on B7 and
accepted an inferior end game instead he
put the bishop back on F3 Bishop takes
F3 came as a very powerful device Queen
takes F3 Knight G5 and suddenly you can
see this Rooks on the H file
coordinating beautifully there's a lot
of problems here for white if you put
the queen on E3 then boom Queen B7 check
and notice how dangerous this queen is
on the diagonal Unstoppable this would
lead to a mating attack if you keep the
queen on the diagonal by playing for
example Queen C6 then you're abandoning
his King your king to his own devices
after just Rook H2 check King F1 and the
very simple either Queen takes B4 or
Rook takes B2 it seems like the uh
Danger on the H file should be
sufficient for Jeffrey to win he is uh
down on time considerably but he's
already played the move Knight G5 and
this looks like it's a completely
winning position for Jeffrey as instead
of taking on F3 with the queen he
decided to take with the Rook but the
same problems Knight G5 The Rook doesn't
have any good sores Rook on H2 is coming
down the board this looks losing for the
white side thank you Alejandro and
indeed it seems like time pressure is
starting to RAR his ugly head and many
mistakes are being made because of that
uh that's right we just came move on the
board from ruang and and on my on my
computer here it was saying saying for
the last 10 15 moves Jeffrey had a big
time disadvantage and now my computer
says he has a Time Advantage right so I
guess rof must have been really
surprised by Bishop B7 right and he he
made some fast moves as black yeah yeah
didn't find the right antidote and uh
after Rook F6 the computer is just
saying that blacks winning blacks attack
down the H file much stronger than
Whit's supposed attack down the f file
that's not really amounting to very much
who would have believed just when white
managed to build that strong Center and
that Bishop on G2 and Pawn on H3 seem to
completely close the gate to the black
Rooks he had so much potential with that
A4 it was amazing night maneuver Knight
F6 to H7 to G5 you don't see that every
day and then eventually the the pawn on
H3 was lost and the floodgates open to
the white king yeah one little mistake
King G2 instead of King F1 that's right
just one mistake will do it yep the
trade of the bishop just accentuated the
H1 A8 diagonal and now and now somehow
uh Kaden trop is is upon PA down and
let's take a look at what happen what's
happening over
here so after after playing C4 I like to
say C4 is explosive for obvious reasons
and it really is explosive in this
position after B takes C4 he didn't take
on C4 because he realized the bishop6 is
going to be overworked we can we can
show the audience that if he takes takes
and then takes the bishop on C4 he loses
the Knight on D7 and White's perfectly
fine here so instead
after B takes C4 being in total shock I
imagine having seen that variation he
played the move Rook C8 and then takes
and now black has compensation for a
pawn black is down a pawn I didn't think
I would be saying that anytime soon and
he played the move Knight to C5 and this
is just a double-edged position now and
the players are done for just minutes to
make the last 10 moves or nine moves
very little time for both players but
White's back in it now totally amazing
turn of events yeah complete turnaround
indeed
the position is still very dangerous for
the white side there are some tricks in
the position and especially in time
pressure this might be difficult but of
course we're going from something that
was almost completely winning for the
black side to something that now is
completely double edged here after
Knight C5 the threat is to go Knight A4
and then Knight C3 check with a lot of
forks he must find the move Queen B4
notice that Queen B4 is a very important
move it pins the knight in a way because
Queen E7 check might be a very annoying
threat if the Knight moves away
therefore this challenges black on how
to continue the attack without the move
Queen B4 black would be winning this is
not what Kaden uh missed of course after
C takes B5 uh the position is already
quite murky and indeed Haron V has
played the move Queen B4 position has
just completely blown up Kaden could
overextend if he's not
careful quite incredible it seems like
with the once they got into time trouble
the game started to resemble lond the
Paris and Len games uh by the people
from the grand chest tour where time
plays such a factor that no matter how
good you are how well calculated you are
it's you have to be on your toes for
every single part of the exercise so to
speak and it's really it's really very
demanding look what happened to to ruang
Lee yeah very difficult to play in time
trouble after
move and the positions are very
demanding it's not it's not just quiet
positions of an ending where you can
make 10 moves in a minute gain time and
no problem here every move might have
irreversible consequences now we have a
game where has which has a lot of trains
I see oh which game the one the one
we're seeing right now some move moven
Queen B4 was played and the threat of
queen7 was ignored Knight A4 so he's
allowing Queen E7 that seems like it's
going to be good for white all of a
sudden Alejandro is this Knight A4 a
mistake or is black still doing okay I'm
cheating a little bit here I don't have
uh the little amount of time that the
players have and I do have a computer
helping me so it's a blunder Knight A4
is not a good move at all after the move
Queen E7 checked you already have to be
very very careful now this is a very
coldblooded move queen king H6 now if
white takes on E6 Knight C3 check King
B2 it seems like there might be a
problem with the position actually King
B2 maybe not the best move uh because
after King B2 you have Knight D1 check
Bishop takes D1 Queen D4 check and still
this is a very complicated position King
B1 you cannot take the bishop on D1
because the Rook on C8 would be hanging
instead there's incredibly coldblooded
move King to C2 taking advantage of the
fact The Rook is hanging so there are no
discovers against the King on C2 this
would be incredible if uh it does happen
but the more obvious version is that
after Queen E7 check this would have to
happen because if Bishop D7 Rook D7
really does look very bad for the uh
black side white has played the move
Queen E7 check and we expect more more
exciting updates from this game which is
just in time pressure in a very
difficult position for both sides thank
you Alejandro and wow not a dull moment
and it seems like we were somewh right
in the amuseum park right it's we have
ups and we have downs and it's like yeah
we thought that Luke couldn't handle the
truth but it looks like he yeah he might
exactly the truth might hurt you know
yeah so the game that looks like it's
well no more blunders but we have a lot
of trades in the game between sha and
asosi he he sacrificed for the Aon just
to clear the Board of every everything
and with the queen and two pawns for
rook and Bishop this should be just a
mup job and he actually Queen E3 was the
40th move time trouble was like his only
enemy this game and this is a really
nice game from
estrosi play a lot of beautiful Mose
yeah he push he ended up queening it to
win his opponent's Queen sacrific for
his opponent's pass pawn and both
players are away from the board I don't
think it's because the game's over
although could be I think it's because
they reach time control and now they can
they can little bit although I think
going to be more relaxed than white for
sure yeah so asosi almost certainly
going to win his game against cha after
very nice tactical sequence starting
with Bishop takes out three really nice
game and as Alejandra pointed out
earlier we might have five decisive
games today yeah always the desirable
result well for us maybe not for the
players for us okay so we have some
craziness in our in our game of the day
between ruang Lee and Jeffrey Jong and
uh I don't know this uh computer says
somebody's winning somebody else is
winning it's equal and um well let's see
if Alejandro has any idea of what's
going on in this in this crazy tactical
battle where both sides have very little
time and we allow him to use the anle
what a crazy position it is for both
sides and I see ruy fangling has one
minute left here the winning idea for uh
Jeffrey was to play the move Rook H1
check doesn't seem like the most obvious
thing in the world right now but it was
winning now if you capture on H1 you
simply allow Queen Queen G2 Checkmate so
this is unplayable and after this you
have to play King E2 Rook H2 check and
this is what seems a little bit
unnatural that you're actually pushing
the king away from the King side but
it's actually this kind of pins attack
with the Rook on H2 and this queen
coming down on B4 that would just finish
off the white king queen on B3 being a
huge threat nothing really to do about
it Queen takes A4 also a very dangerous
possibility instead he decided to play
Rook H2 immediately trying to trap the
King on F1 but here Ren came up with one
of the two really dangerous moves that
he had Knight F5 check at fantastic idea
the point is that here after Rook H2 I
cannot capture on G4 because again check
made on the G2 square but after Knight
F5 check if you for example move the
king then Rook takes G4 now this Rook is
covering the G2 square if Knight F5
check you capture then after Rook takes
G4 you have really no choice but to
capture my Rook Queen takes G5 and the
queen is enough for a Perpetual check
that would be an amazing finish to this
game not five check secures a draw here
for white at least and unless well
Jeffrey decides to over push he has to
allow the Perpetual that's on the board
right now or he risks losing and he did
take the Knight Alejandra he just played
GF and we
have the draw was agreed and he put the
kings in the middle wow what an amazing
several turn of events that game and
what a just result right yeah at the end
of the at the end of the day both sides
were uh in control both sides lost
control a draw both very excited after
that game I would be shaking yeah
because they were hoping to have a
decisive game and decize their ongoing
10year duel that's right of 37 games
it's not the rubber game anymore yes
instead of 181 17 to one side it's going
to be a four
draw in that uh ongoing battle a
beautiful game really a beautiful game
and I think that uh I would love to hear
from uh to have Jeffrey here explain a
little bit maybe both both players yeah
both players one one we'll start with
Jeffrey and then uh have rof also come
and explain his side of the game wow
what an amazing what an amazing turn the
players like to prove me wrong as soon
as I explain there'll probably be five
deive games immediate draw agre
immediately but listen this is this is
anybody who says something about draws
in chess this is like a a 44 draw in
soccer you know it's like a really you
really get your money's worth you can't
say that that was a boring z00 or like a
some repetition after move 12 no no it's
amazing this is an astonishing game
really full of fireworks this is just
round one of nine yeah I mean if this is
this is I don't are we going to last
yeah exactly this is amazing in fact uh
another another game that's went the way
one of Alejandro's variations was after
Queen E7 check in the game Luke Harman
vadi Kaden Trove he did play King H6
Queen E6 Knight C3 check and will will
luk play the coldblooded king C2 that's
a hard move to play I think I but I
think for a logical person like him it
really has to be first of all it's it's
the best solution second because but
according to the internet both sides
have less than a minute oh so that's
going to be king C2 is hard to play with
20 seconds on your clock yeah so perh
the Camas should really concentrate on
the game if he could and he did move his
King obviously he made a move and he
went to A1 the one move we didn't talk
about King A1 the one legal move yeah
because now after Knight takes D1 Queen
D4 check could be annoying right so
that's why the D A1 might not be the
best Square so we're expecting Knight
Tak D1 right very difficult very
difficult to play KN to to play King C2
and with no time on your clock wow and
they're moving very very fast
and I don't know if we can get a closeup
of that board probably not but let's
take a look at it as it is here we
go right here comes is this an Arbiter
there standing there no I think it's one
of the players it's one of the players
oh he's standing pretty close right and
there's a Perpetual check possibility in
this game also white can play Queen H3
check Queen D7 check of course of course
so after I exlain there would be five
decisive games you might the players the
players just can't stop drawing they
can't do it right W so King A1 and
Knight takes D1 was played and queen
H3 feeling this is I think that the draw
is coming amazing wow a second game
where both sides were again Kaden
trapped his opponent with Rook takes D5
the opponent refused the draw he was in
a losing position then Kaden started
playing some strange moves and was down
upon where white could have probably
gotten a winning position with King C2
and once again the game is is is
stepping towards a draw and again a fair
result I
guess yeah amazing and queen D7 check
this is they're repeating moves D7 King
H6 making both players happier making
sure they won't lose on time getting
closer to the time control they're both
deep in thought because they both still
want to win and it's really funny
somebody's going to look at the cross
table and say oh draws in the junior as
well but no this these are not okay and
actually why can play for the win here
as Alejandra pointed out why can play
Queen takes D1 here uhhuh you can but
first you he moves and then I think he
already repeated one so he can't do it
again so Queen takes D1 and he's still
back in the driver's seat holy
cow what move are they on 37 yeah this
White's thinking about his 30th
move well we have a lot of crazy he's
under a minute he's under a
minute
wow and he's looking visibly
nervous and he played looks like he took
the
yeah yeah and the computer likes white
white has more
material wow an amazing game incredible
can you
refresh yeah Queen takes D1 was played
there we go both sides still have less
than a minute less than under a minute
but okay only only two or three moves to
go so they're not going to lose on time
but yeah Kaden's not going to be happy
regardless of the result of this game C4
just a just a terrible move and then the
followup Knight C5 Knight A4 allowing
Queen to infiltrate on E7 just letting
let no trouble at all an extra pawn and
then things just collapsed right right
so okay I think we should leave this
game for a moment and uh I think we
should visit Alejandro because Alejandro
is with a guest okay and a guest is the
highest rated player in the tournament
uh a player who has been really really
on far in this in the year 2016 Grand
Master Jeff and on we go to you
Alejandro and Jeffrey well guys thank
you here with Grandmaster Jeffrey shung
I've had the pleasure of knowing him for
many many years now thanks to the Dallas
chess club Jeffrey how did you feel
about the game today you must have felt
it was out of your reach at some point
uh yeah today it was a very interesting
game uh but for the most part I thought
I was in trouble but at the end it got
out of control and maybe I had something
when did you feel that you really uh let
this game go when did you think I right
now I'm in trouble well actually I think
I messed something up in the opening
because usually black wants some Queen
side attack but I didn't get anything so
yeah this position is already difficult
for black uh but I thought my only
counter play was in the center so that's
what I ended up doing now we were
analyzing this very key move A4 did you
consider this at all no I was thinking
about uh E5 for him E5 immediately
instead of
A4 ah but yeah it doesn't work Rook
takes H3 oh there some interesting ideas
with Rook takes H3 and now the
coordination of the Bishops and The Rook
very powerful down this diagonal yeah
but A4 was a very good move by him yeah
here I spent a lot of time because I
didn't know what to do I didn't see this
Rook takes H3 idea because I thought B4
E5 again mhm B4 but actually I think I
have to play B4 otherwise his Rook gets
in theame the computer did agree with
you that B4 was probably the best move
and after C takes B4 you found this
really cool idea of Knight F6 Knight H7
Knight G5 how did you come up with this
no but I'm actually not sure it's that
strong because uh in the game just said
it's cool I didn't
say Yeah well yeah I wanted to put my
now on G5 so that's one way to do it but
okay yeah I I thought he he still was
clearly better as the engine says but
after Rook
A1 you play Knight
H7 E5 and then you were forced to Clos
down the diagonal we saw this during the
game and then maybe here the move E6 was
yeah I think that he was about to play
but then he had second thoughts I guess
F takes E6 though he didn't see anything
so so clear yeah the computer just says
that positionally you're kind of busted
and after the rerouting of the Knight
Knight E2 Knight F4 your position was
already kind of difficult now did you
feel that you have a win in this game
though uh maybe at the end I thought it
started to slip away from him a bit so
no I mean he was getting really uh
undertime yeah look yeah I think maybe
where you really missed something was
this move King F1 you decided to play
Rook H2 did you miss the idea of yeah
completely missed otherwise I can just
win the piece by force you can how did
you win a piece by force just a rook H
one Rook H1 we saw no I thought Rook H2
won the house but okay Rook yeah here
it's not K2 it's just completely winning
Queen G2 ahuh Queen G2 may be the
easiest solution and
then yeah for example Queen F2 which is
yeah it's just completely Queen F2 you
can even just trade right and win the
Knight on
G3 yeah anything yeah that would be one
of them anyways right just trade off
here and after for example King takes E1
you can just take on G3 with the Rook or
yeah what I did was just too fancy so
rook2 was a little too creative in this
position trying to Chuck immediately
yeah just didn't make sense because the
lines are even more complex if he plays
Rook F2 or something so it
just was a very sensible decision yeah
well that cost you was half a point but
overall a very crazy game it was up and
down it seemed like you were in the
driver's seat only till the end it was
you were definitely in trouble for most
of the game yeah I I am fortunate uh
because at the beginning it was very
difficult but yeah well do you consider
uh rang to be one of your top opponents
in this tournament or who else are you
looking forward to play that you think
is really going to be a challenge for
you in this event uh actually I think
all 10 players are very challenging so I
I can't say there's anybody in
particular they're all very strong well
thank you Jeffrey this was definitely an
exciting game thank you for all the
fireworks that you guys provided in
round one and we'll see what else is
going on in this
game thank you Alejandra and Jeffrey wow
what insight into the game really and a
very uh very objective uh Outlook by
Jeffrey as expected of course at the
game and again I think that uh once
again I'll say the draw was a real Fair
result in this game it
had big advantages Jee was winning near
the end exactly and and and before that
he might have trick though exactly easy
to miss exactly it's it's very
counterintuitive kind of you think that
that's like one of the most protective
squares and all of a sudden I moov like
this and uh yeah things have changed so
very very exciting uh game and I would
love to hear uh what we call a second
opinion I guess yeah and we can only get
that from uh the uh opponent of um of
Jeff young in a minute or two we are
going to talk to his opponent ruang Lee
and get uh his Viewpoint of the game uh
in the meantime do we have any quick
development before we go there yeah we
can we can talk about some of the other
games it looks like Luke Harman vat has
a winning position against Ken technical
just over just an amazing turnaround
just like in in the other game um and
ostrovski looks like he's not having any
trouble at all uh in his in his game
with Nicholas cha he's got two extra
pass pawns his King's going to walk down
the board and this is just a question of
when it's going to end right and of
course aot Chandra has a big Advantage
uh he had a big advantage against
Michael Brown and let him back into the
game by playing a little bit hastily
with Rick takes B2 the both players have
made the time control now things are
going to slow down we're going to have
interviews people are going to get to
move 40 and start thinking a long time
so it's uh it's good that the players
that are still playing get to think a
long time when we get to interview the
other he also very considerate yeah very
nice well be horrible time while we're
trying to interview the players who have
just finished their games exactly so
amazing that we have uh that we that we
have this draw and we have other games
that seem like they're going to be
decisive uhuh and in the meantime I
think it's time to go to Alejandro with
the rulee for a second opinion on that
super exciting first round game to
finish from the uh junior championships
Alejandro take it away I'm here with Ru
Fang Lee soon to be grandmas I'm sure R
Fang do you know how many times you
played Jack Jeffrey no like maybe 20
maybe 20 lowballing at this is your 38th
time playing with Jeffrey according to
uschess.org uh what did you feel about
your 38th encounter how did it go um it
went smoothly at first and then
something bad happened all right well
more or less where did you uh drop the
ball where did things start going wrong
in this game I think when I got to like
15 minutes I started playing some bad
moves some bad moves starting do you
have any feel
um maybe after E5 E5 you didn't like uh
E5 I liked and then afterwards I didn't
like Jeffrey was mentioning that at this
point you were reaching your for your e
Pawn maybe thinking about playing E6 but
you decided not to do it yeah I was
looking at that but I thought he would
just take yeah E6 Pawn takes and we're
looking at it with Jeffy that after the
move Knight E2 with the Knight I didn't
see Knight E2 I was only looking at some
Queen E3 Queen E3 in this position also
quite strong actually with the idea of
Queen E5 some kind of domination on the
dark squares the computer really liked
this and it said that you had an
advantage without any real risk but
after Queen E3 Bishop C8 things got
really dangerous very quickly yeah I
actually missed Bishop C8 I didn't think
he could give up D5 and we're assuming
that this bishop moves might be a
problem for you did you also miss that
after King G2 there is this move Bishop
B7 yeah I was missing a lot of stuff
well that's happens on time pressure we
notice that after Knight takes H3 you
still according to computer some
Advantage after the move King F1 just
making your king a little safer uh what
did you feel about this position after
Knight takes H3 so my idea was like I
thought he had to play Bishop E6 so I
wanted to play King G2 and then if
Bishop E6 I could take take and double
on the f ah you wanted to keep the Rook
open here for the f um yeah for f Rook
but unfortunately that was a little bit
too aggressive after King G2 Bishop B7
well you were lucky to find a draw but
what did you were you expecting here
after the move King F1 yeah I thought
Rook H1 was probably just winning mhm
Rook H1 was winning but uh how soon did
you find this move Knight F5 just
drawing the game something that he
completely
blundered I saw Knight F5 actually a bit
earlier uh cuz I was at first actually I
was expecting Rook H2 as well Rook H2
was your first choice thinking of Queen
G2 Checkmate but of course you found
this really nice resource Knight F5
forcing the draw a little bit fortunate
for both players actually to finish in a
draw how do you feel about the result of
drawing the highest rated player in the
event I think it should be pretty
satisfactory pretty satisfactory all
right well this is only your fourth draw
against Jeffrey surprisingly and it was
a very exciting one thank you for the
fireworks and good luck moving forward
into the tournament we go back to aiv
and Ben thank you ruang and Alejandro
man this was really I've seen lots of
draws in my life and I would say that
this one comes up somewhere on the top
on top just an exciting game you really
get everything you can imagine one side
is pushing and having a big Advantage
another one is coming from the dead and
taking taking over the players even took
a break and played E4 B4 T okay now back
to the exactly exactly almost like a
little it's just a fantastic game and
even though it's not a decisive result
I'm completely all adrad and up because
of this game I'm I'm really hyper about
it and it's no less exciting than any
decisive game that could happen uh now
and we have the assist Arbiter here Mike
kmer making sure things are all in the
up and up as always of course we have I
see that in the ostrovski in the Czech
ostrovski game lots of simplification uh
yeah actually if we can look at that he
I thought that in this position black
was going to move his King up the board
and white would resign eventually but
instead black traded down to a winning
end game it's also reasonable going into
this King and pawn ending I actually
looked at a similar King and pawn ending
about 25 years ago with the F Pawn
instead of the E Pawn uhhuh and I
noticed that as long as Black's Pawn is
on H7 he's winning because of the tempos
at the very end of course and so he is
leaving his Pawn on H7 and okay so
they've played very natural move since
then the computer sees all the way to
the end of the game of course so there's
very few legal moves so it knows that
black is winning it sees all the way to
mate actually and it's fair to say that
white is playing by inertia right
because yeah he knows he's losing too
but you
know when you can keep keep playing and
what ends up happening is if I could
just continue what I think will happen
uh White eventually get stalemated so
we'll we'll do that we'll stalemate him
and now if Black's Pawn was on H6 or H5
this would actually be a draw but
because Black's Pawn hasn't moved yet
he's ready for either white move for
example after the move H4 we play H6 and
then we unal mate him you can do it
either way and we of course make a queen
and obviously if he plays H3 it's the
same thing we play H5 and then we unal M
him again so as long as Black's Pawn is
on H7 there's there's no issue and
that's how the game will end although
czecher looks pretty confident but uh
okay maybe it's just looking confident
maybe he knows the game is going I think
he just looks resigned to the the result
I think he from an hour so this is the
current position on the board and black
and just play E2 check and King E3 and
and the game is over and um actually uh
because it's an e- Pawn there might be
more winning chances for black if he
makes a mistake because sometimes you
can lose your E Pawn and win the H Pawn
and still win you lose your F Pawn and
win the h
then you don't win because in forever
yeah so it's possible that everything
wins although of course E2 Che is the
best E2 Che was played okay always good
to check against cze uhhuh and King G1
allows m one so he going to play King E1
or not play at all yeah he'll probably
play King E1 and then after King E3 I'm
guessing he'll resign because you see
that all the H pawn moves lose yep he
did play King E1 black will play King E3
and I think white will resign there
that's my guess yeah
probably yeah King E3 was played the
Lost hurdle yeah and yeah whether you
play H4 H3 you lose the tempo issue the
black king is going to move and then
Black's going to get an extra Queen yeah
and this is what he saw when when he
sacrificed his Queen for the rook and
Bishop knowing this is an easily winning
end game play he's testing him to make
sure that he understand the tempo
situation yep he's got to he doesn't
have to play H H H5 here play King F3 or
King D3 and also
win right but I think he'll play yeah
he'll play H5 he'll play H5 and he will
resign here I don't think he'll play
h4m resigned okay very exciting game
again and a very good uh show by good
game by ex especially in time trouble
where he made some really serious mov
and I would like to see him as the
winner um we'll get to hear we can get
Alexander down here later and explain
how he found this uh he really this you
know Alejandro was explaining what with
the help of the engine you know the unle
as you call him Queen B8 and he played
and he played all the moves he played
all the all the
best with very little time on his clock
okay he's an experienced I am listen and
he's uh he's been going he's uh he just
finished his second year in in baru
college in New York and he is of course
seeking uh future in finance so I guess
that every once in a while you get this
just hunger and you really get to play
uh you know kind of under less much less
pressure you're not pursuing titles or
norms and you know you have another
career so chess is really a hobby and
becomes fun again but I hope this isn't
a harburger of things to come because I
told you when I go to tournaments
certain people do well on bad and I said
chea has bad tournaments when I'm there
so I hope it's I hope it's not me I hope
it's not you I know G's not going to
play in this tournaments so
yeah so okay let's see what else is uh
two games are done and three more going
and let's uh see what happens in the a
Wonder game uh actually let's have a
look at at this position here in in
Kaden's game I think we have Alejandro
and he has a he's very opinionated about
White's winning chances here and let's
take a look I have been impressed by
Alexander rovi's handling of that
position with black he played a very
clean game against cze uh Nicholas
wasn't up to par and he just lost the
game I thought that Alexander played the
game of the day as far as Precision goes
the if there's an opposite award for
that it would definitely go to Luke
Harmon vot and Kaden tras they seem to
be blundering the advantage back and
forth somehow after Queen D6 which is a
completely winning position King G6 was
played and here uh White has several
ways of playing but the most logical way
is to Simply bring the bishop back to D1
put it on B3 which is obviously its best
diagonal and start trying to Checkmate
the opponent uh the King on G6 would not
feel safe at all you can also put the
Knight on E2 Knight C3 Knight D5 you
have a lot of choices here after for
example Queen takes G2 you simply win
with Queen E6 attacking The Rook on C8
and this is really bad position but
instead Knight D3 was played which is a
pretty horrible blunder he must only be
counting on the fact that Queen takes E2
as a move which would indeed lose to
Knight takes C5 check you can uh
calculate the variations out pretty
easily for example if the king runs to
the king side then after this there is
this really nice move Knight G6 check
with Queen G3 coming but that's not the
only resource that black has he doesn't
actually have to take on E2 the move
Queen G1 check King B2 Queen takes G2
would be extremely powerful the problem
is that after Knight takes E5 King H5
suddenly you don't have your Pawn to
push to the G4 Square so the King on H5
is pretty safe notice that there is this
threat on E2 the bishop hangs with check
E5 is also hanging that would be a huge
problem after King B2 Queen takes G2
already there's no good way of defending
this bishop on G2 if the Knight retreats
to C1 The Rook can trade itself off for
the Knight eliminating this defense and
that would give an approximate equality
to the game this is not exactly a good
way of continuing for white he must have
overestimated his chances after Knight
D3 on the attack now Kaden has to find
the move Queen G1 check or he will lose
Queen E2 gets mated he must find Queen
G1 check first if he for example takes
on G2 immediately then after Knight
takes E5 King H5 the big difference is
that after Queen D7 I'm attacking that
uh Rook on C8 and threading things on
the king side including Queen takes H7
Checkmate and queen takes E2 is of
course not check a very big difference
in the position after uh Knight D3 it's
Now Cadence uh turn to think he has
plenty of time to find his only saving
move I expect him to find it but
considering the amount of blunders that
we' seen in this game nothing would
surprise me anymore wow Alejandro thank
you for this amazing yeah it's like this
game this uh how should we say amusement
ride of a game is is not done just when
we thought that uh uh it was over like
you said they got pulled back in players
don't want to end the game they want to
just keep playing right he white refuses
a draw black gets into a winning
position and
uh all of a sudden he blunders he goes
the wrong way and speaking shocking
results we have a result AKA Chandra and
Michael BR Drew their game wow and
that's I guess another draw in kind of a
seesaw seesaw kind of I knew the players
hated me but this much I said five
decisive games look at all and then draw
immediately draw well they meant the me
decisive decisive potentially decisive
potentially decisive they could be
decisive right right right now we have
three the game only went one move past
the time control I guess the players had
enough and white had some good
counterplay down the f file um quite
amazing I would love to have uh
Alejandro look at this game one more
time but with a guest and we have the
reigning us Junior Champion I am AA
Chandra with him to explain a little bit
what happened in this second or third
Amusement R of a game seesaw up and down
let's go back let's go alandro thanks
aiv a you had a crazy game what happened
are you actually satisfied with this
result um no not at all I mean I felt
like I was much better at some point but
I probably rushed things with Rook D3
should have probably just kept attention
with Queen E5 and I'm probably just much
better in this position you mean Rook D3
you felt was a mistake you thought
keeping the tension with Queen E5 which
was another interesting possibility was
better yeah cuz it's I mean after Rook
D3 white has to take on e4 while after
Queen E5 he has no force to move so it's
harder to manage for him there so I
thought that would have been a better
try and now did you feel that by this
point your advantage was pretty much
gone no I still felt like I was better
but um uh after he played I think the
best defense Rook E8 Queen F3 I didn't
really see any way to increase my
advantage somehow his King's not getting
M it uh which position is this for
example Queen F3 Rook D1 King G2 Rook D2
King F1 queen queen D3 doesn't work cuz
he has King E1 I think yeah the computer
was liking Queen D3 King E1 trading the
the Rooks and going into a very
favorable Queen end game but also uh we
were looking at the position we didn't
like Rook takes B2 at all we likeed this
move King f8 simply securing the king
for the time being H King f8 yeah I
totally missed that move so it's like a
prophylactic against rookie 8 right and
now the the King on F1 feels very unsafe
the King on f8 guards itself against
rookie eight the computer said you had
great winning chances however the
opening what did you feel about it did
you miss this move Knight G5 early on I
mean no I saw it but I didn't really
think it was that I mean I thought I
could just play G6 um and I didn't
really see anything too dangerous but uh
yeah okay when I had to play H5 on the
15 Mo I started getting a little worried
because I don't want to make pawn moves
around my king but I didn't see any
clear way for him to take advantage of
it so I I think he should have Castle
long he left his King in the center
which was quite risky I right we saw
this move G5 which Ben categorized as a
blunder and I have to agree just leaving
the king in the center allowing you a
huge attack before this move the game
was kind of complicated expected long
castle and I was going to play B5 then
the computer showing that but yeah I
think it should be equal with corre play
now at the end you decided to agree to a
draw after the move Queen E6 yeah he
claimed three-fold and it was a correct
claim so I didn't I didn't bother so I
just figured yeah so after Rook F4 Queen
E6 uh he played the move Rook D4 here
right yeah so Queen E5 he played Rook F4
Queen E6 and then okay you felt that you
just didn't have the advantage anymore
yeah I I I didn't even see any way to uh
you know inre the advantage I mean it's
probably close to equal now so at the
end it wasn't such a big deal I guess
definitely a topsy turby round uh I feel
that you were much better and I think
you felt the same I saw your mood coming
into the studio uh well you have to
recover from this I think that having
winning chances and not converting it
might hurt you a little bit but a draw
with the black piece is not a bad start
yeah thanks well thanks aad and we're
going to go back with a Ben thank you
very much aat and Alejandro and indeed
you can hear from the voice and the tone
of AA that he's a bit disappointed about
the result probably rightfully so trying
to figure out who's quieter him or
Jeffrey yeah but here I think he's a bit
somber because he had probably Great
Expectations somewhere in the late
middle game uh for a completely
different result hard to blame him for
that now Kaden did find the the only way
to continue he checked on G1 first after
Knight D3 which is a blunder throwing
away his his winning position Queen G1
and then Queen takes G2 pinning the
bishop and stopping the G4 check idea
which was winning in other variations
exactly just like expected by Alejandro
and and we have a big fight here and uh
I don't know what the result of this
game is going to be and who would guess
right it becomes really a bit of a of a
potluck with the the late late late game
mistakes that uh that are made they
played so many good moves so many
interesting plans and then all of a
sudden out of the blue we have uh mini
blunders um right now I think that for a
computer if a computer was involved with
white I think I'll be less concerned but
the human is playing white with a rook
and a queen especially when he had this
big advantage and he probably thought
Knight D3 is just winning he thought was
over the com all the other variations
and this is the one variation where
black can keep fighting exactly so the
combination of uh you know losing your
mood a little bit about those mistakes
and losing your pawns and uh the the
piece is being so clumsy the bishop on
E2 and the Knight on D3 it's it could be
only discouraging well we have a clear
winner so far in the tournament we have
somebody in clear first place that's
right and probably the game of the day
although there were very exciting games
all around the uh the Horn uh but let's
go to Alejandro who is now with
Alexandro rovski who won a real pretty
game Let's Take a Look well Alexander
it's been a very top Su tury round we've
seen in many games that the advantage
has flown back and forth but your game
seemed very very clean tell us a little
bit about it uh yeah I think I did a
pretty good job I was pretty happy with
the position I got from the opening and
then we got into this isolated pawns
position uh and I I really like this
move B3 that I played and after that he
started thinking for maybe about 20
minutes and made a blunder yeah this
move B3 which Ben liked a lot the idea
of moving the Knight to B4 I assume
right yeah and I had this idea in a
previous move where there was a pair of
knights on the board but in this
situation I expected Knight takes
C6 okay this and this if I if I was to
go B3 without um Knight D7 then he keeps
a pair of minor pieces on the board so I
don't think it's as good right so here
can take but in the game
continuation after Knight C6 okay I was
expecting I was going to go Rook C6 and
I thought this was a better version
because I get one more pair of knights
off the board and I I thought it was
more comfortable here of I see the
engine isn't giving me much of an
advantage but I was feeling very happy
here yeah don't worry tooo much about
the engine you know isolated Pawn
positions are not its specialty but we
really like the fact that after the move
uh Queen G5 you found this really nice
F3 Bishop takes F3 you were in severe
Time trou by this point what was taking
you so long oh why was I in time
pressure at this point not sure but this
bishop F3 move fortunately I didn't uh
think too long because I saw it from uh
when he played Queen D4 I already saw it
so I maybe double checked it a little
bit uh yeah but I had this one move
where I thought for 22 minutes and then
I and I and probably that was the worst
thing I did this game I did not manage
my time too well but fortunately I
didn't have to uh it did it didn't come
back to haunt me yeah this bishop F3
very flashy move and after that well it
was pretty much Game Over You converted
a very nice win a nice transition there
into the pawn end game here after King
G2 Queen takes C2 very well calculated
we felt it was uh very clean and
congratulations on well so far being the
clear first here at the US junor 2016
thank you well congratulation Alexander
and uh yeah indeed we have to say that
uh all the games were excited exciting
but this game from beginning to end was
played very well very well played
especially in time trouble where
everybody else managed to kind of uh no
you have the advantage no no no I insist
you will have it he just decided no I'm
going to have it and I'm not going to
let gol players very polite yeah very
polite but Alexander is a New Yorker
he's from Brooklyn he's not going to
give you uh no so he he did the right
thing and of course uh earned the only
full point so far and a very very
impressive I lived in Brooklyn twice and
I'm very
polite oh moving on exactly so we
haven't looked at a wonders game in a
long time and we see them playing here a
Wonder could have basically just won a
piece if he had retreated his night on
C3 earlier right and instead he decided
to go into this winning end game and it
seems like it's more and more winning as
we continue the bishop on B7 is terrible
white has ideas like Rook E8 G5 Rook G8
Checkmate which would be very annoying
for black because the black king is
getting sort of trapped here um Whit's
up a pawn of course the pawn on C6 is
terrible lots of space black would like
to take that pawn off the board and then
his position would improve so possible
past Pawn for white better King for
white better min winning position um
probably could have won easier but this
is looks like a lot of fun also I would
take white he show some the most s more
sadistic way to exactly to gain the
point okay and at this time while
they're thinking about how to continue
in the ending and the other game is also
reaching some sort of uh uh it's going
to take some moves it's not going to end
up in the next few minutes I think that
this is a great time for us to take uh
potentially a last break or second to
last break of the day uh please stay
with us because again there going to be
some uh exciting games coming up except
we finish the games coming up and just
so you don't get bored in the
technicalities of the ending we will
leave you with another tactical puzzle
that you could solve and uh then we'll
come back and Alejandra will decipher it
to you please stay with us and we'll be
back in just a few
moment hi I'm Mike maeni I've been part
of some great clubs and now I'm part of
another the chess club and Scholastics
Center of St Louis right here in the
chess capital of the us our world
renowned Center is dedicated in teaching
playing and promoting the sport because
chess has been proven to enhance
academic performance our Scholastic
outreach program now works with over 100
Schools so whether you've played for
years or never before come experience
all that chess has to
[Music]
offer
for
[Music]
there's a weekend vacation one tank trip
in a nearby City you won't want to SK St
Louis
Museum
art upcr
twisty
[Music]
Louis
welcome back once more to the uh live
coverage of the 2016 US Junior Clos
Chess Championship coming to you from
the chess Center and chess club and
Scholastic Center of St Louis when we
left you two games were ongoing now we
have only one but before we talk about
the result and get to interview one of
the players we have left you with a
puzzle the solution of is going to be
deciphered by Alejandro Alejandro
go ahead please well the solution to the
puzzle is very simple actually it's more
about avoiding Temptation you might be
thinking the solution was Knight takes
D3 Queen takes D3 B4 exploiting this pin
down the file but there's actually no
pin after Knight E2 both the bishop and
the Knight are defending this Rook you
might have been thinking maybe B4
immediately with the idea of maybe after
Knight E2 having some tactic but that's
not the case the idea was simply to play
Queen A5 attacking the Knight
reinforcing this threat on C3 and
suddenly because there is a pin on the
Knight there there is no way to defend
White's position for example after
Knight E2 you take advantage of the pin
on the queen Knight takes D3 check just
would win the house so instead of that
in the game white decided to play King
E2 but a very nice finish Knight takes
D3 was played and now after King takes
D3 the only way to keep the defense on
the C3 night the move Queen A3 was
played pinned down the third rank B4
next move is UN voidable white played a
desperate move E5 and after B4 he was
absolutely forced to resign a very nice
finish from Kaden trough in this game
with the King being lured all the way up
to D3 a very nice Queen A5 patient move
finishing off the
game thank you very much Alejandro for
your uh explaining of the puzzle indeed
a beautiful game that went well say
again looks like a gfell that went well
for black yes that looks like a very
very very positive greenr for black and
uh I propose green FS for black and and
Trove being on the black side of it uh
his game with uh Luke Haron vatti has
ended in a draw again one of those
seesaw games he was uh uh could that
draw could have happened actually two or
three hours ago that's right uh it would
have been a very exciting very flashy
kind of a draw right uh his opponent uh
decided not to go for it decided to
suffer a pawn down and was really really
worse then he took over after Kaden lost
his head a little bit in time trouble
and uh
then he allowed Kaden back to in the
game but instead of me talking about it
let's hear it from the horse's mouth as
the say goes and we're going to go to
Alejandro and our
newly uh newly crowned uh Eagle Scout
and the long-term grandmas Kaden Trove
well kayen we'll be talking more about
your Eagle Scout promotion I think you
receive it this week um well I I mean I
guess I've fulfilled all the
requirements there will be kind of a
celebration for it but um you know I'll
probably have my court of honor a little
bit later um you know because of this
tournament couldn't quite you fit it in
but you know still really excited you
know I have everything I just um the the
event coming up should be should be
great you know hoping to promote um the
combination of scouting and the chess
Mar patch especially um you know with
with the great benefits of both I think
they're a great combination absolutely
great for the Community this combination
well let's talk a little bit about your
game was this the most precise game of
chust that you have ever played no I
thought okay in the opening um went
about as well as I could have hoped for
you had this blow Rook takes D5 and what
did you think did you think you were
winning no I thought it was a draw
actually
um when when he first played uh B like
okay so if you go back when I played a
takes B5 I thought okay Bishop D4 and I
just play Rook D5 it's it's pretty clear
uh and then once he actually played
Bishop D4 I I spent quite a bit of time
here because I realized after Rook takes
D5 e takes D5 is interesting and
actually I think it's probably just a
draw um here I should play Bishop F5 of
course uh King A1 and now okay I'm down
a rook I have to play Rook takes A2 it's
funny I'm down a rook I have to
sacrifice another Rook it's my only
option he has to take um Queen A8 and it
looks like he's he's pretty much just
getting mated but if you really look at
this position I I just don't think it's
there uh Queen A4 um is what I was
planning on uh King C3 and then I was
going to play Queen
A5 and if he plays B4 interestingly I
think this is actually better for black
um of course if you look down the line
um it it doesn't quite look like it
because uh at least what I calculated
white gets two Rooks for a bishop which
or two Rooks and a bishop for Queen
which is usually considered good but
because of my my pawns and you know this
this bishop on F1 this Rook on H1 um it
actually turns out to be pretty good
yeah and we were calculating all of that
actually during our analysis we also
thought that this was just a draw now
you were able to play Rook takes D5
without punishment he did not take on D5
and you emerged pretty much just up a
pawn where did things start going South
um I I think I just got a little too
aggressive too quickly and um somewhere
I just I just totally spaced like
something obvious you know I I was
trying to figure out some different
things and all of a sudden I realized
like what the crap am I doing and uh
then we hit time pressure and there was
just a few things that I I just like
kept missing here and there so what do
you think what's your first mistake um
okay I think maybe C5 already wasn't the
best I mean I think it's definitely fine
fine um I don't know if it's NE I mean
it's possible it's good okay Knight C1
was good
um somehow I don't know what yeah the
computer is saying Queen B6 um I was
kind of debating between Queen B6 and C4
but for the wrong reasons I thought okay
C4 what I played I'm like oh maybe Rook
D6 ideas um it's not so clear and then
I'm like okay I have Knight C5 and then
he just takes then forget that there was
some problems on this yeah I just I mean
it's it's one of those things you're
calculating all these complicated
variations after Rook takes D5 you know
it's all forced you you think you you're
calculating well you're playing well and
then all of a
sudden you just start keep calculating
complicated moves instead of calculating
you know simple moves and you know that
was my problem is I kept calculating
like the complicated variations where
the one I missed was just like the most
obvious first thing you should think
about right um now you saw yourself
actually in some trouble perhaps from
over pushing the
position yeah I I actually I don't know
I I kind of panicked a little bit here
[Music]
um yeah I mean I definitely feel like I
should be okay maybe even still pushing
but it's not so clear I got to this
position with uh Knight C5 you played
the good move Queen B4 and then you went
for it you went Knight
A4 did you think that this was good or
just said in time trouble I'm going to
mess up the game
um honestly it was really hard to
calculate everything I had a feeling um
I I missed okay after Queen E7 what he
played uh King H6 Queen takes Knight C3
I thought King C2 maybe and yeah the
computer's saying King C2 is indeed a
very powerful but an unnatural move yeah
I I wasn't sure I was trying to figure
it after King C2 um Queen A4 or King D2
Queen B4 it was complicated but the
computer did like white in that position
yeah I I had a feeling white was good
there but I I couldn't quite see it I
was hoping in TI pressure yeah and then
he plays here and I'm just
fine and
then um yeah I I I know this one was a
mistake CU I I thought I'm like oh I
should play queen king G5 limit his
options and I got down to about 5
seconds and I think I just kind of
panicked and played King G7
um Queen D7 check and suddenly you saw
yourself losing the Knight on yeah I
just I missed Queen takes D1
um now you were a little bit fortunate
here in this position after Queen D2
check G5 uh your opponent might have
also been on the blundering side after
Knight D3 did you see that I think maybe
I influenced him by my earlier play all
right um yeah I was really surprised by
Knight D3 I think he felt like he had an
advantage and the problem is like it's
not so easy I mean even though it's like
he's he's up a pawn he has two pieces
for a rook which is also considered very
good um you know it's it's hard for him
to develop right away and I think he he
felt that like he just wanted to win
right away he was excited he you know it
finally clearly changed in his favor and
I think he just got excited a little too
soon um and you know of course okay I
don't think Queen G1 seems a little off
it seems like of course Queen G1 doesn't
work but somehow it all kind of yeah it
all worked out for you after you1 and
everything is a yeah and here I I was
feeling okay I was after I had played
I'm like okay you know it's it's a draw
now it's we're good like I mean okay of
course you know earlier I definitely had
hopes to win but just kind of that
practical side of me after you making so
many mistakes I just figured you know I
a draw is is definitely good like just
to start and kind of get into the
tournament
um makes me feel good in the end overall
well a solid draw well perhaps not that
solid for starting here for Kaden Tru
and I think that we have a result in the
last game and we'll go back to have even
been for more of that thank you aleandro
and you
Grand
J very nice because he said he's going
to be official all soon and while they
were talking about this exciting game
and it's really as I'm watching the game
as I'm watching they're talking about
the game even after it's already ended
there's like it's almost like watching a
movie a second time when you know the
outcome but still it's very uh it's kind
of amazing really a lot of amazing ups
and downs in that game from Rook D5 the
declination of the draw declining of the
draw and then both sides having so many
opportunities there um really games
today absolutely and we an interview
second decisive results with a Wonder U
winning his game against Michael bodak
and
um yeah and uh I'm assuming we're going
to have a Wonder as a guest very very
shortly to talk a little bit about his
game and um let's let's see just for the
record let's take a look at the last few
moves Ben can you show it on the yeah
sure that F Pawn was getting pretty
strong and it started with the move F5
in this position and um he traded on F5
the bishop on B7 has been bad for I
don't know I don't know how long
uh since we started the broadcast King
F4 white has a better Rook a better
Bishop a better King a better pass pawn
and pawn that's it that's it but other
than that black was fine and black is in
Zan ex black can't do anything so he
tried to move his King up but that
didn't last very long he saved his Pawn
on H7 but the pawn is strong on F6 black
tried one last trick Bishop A6 hoping
for Bishop takes A6 and then Rook takes
the Rook on on G8 and even even here
Black's not winning amazing computer
doesn't say Black's winning so after
Bishop A6 of course a Wonder just
retreated his Bishop to B3 and okay
black is out of his one tricks one trick
wasn't enough even though tricks are for
kids yeah and F7 is very very hard
speaking of kids and speaking of yes
speaking of our younger player in the
tour youngest player of the tournament
International Master Aang just fresh off
his uh great success in the Continental
in El Salvador where he made a GM Norm
beating very strong players like I I
believe he beat buzon from Cuba very I
mean almost 2700 player and let's go to
Alejandro for more insight about the
game want congratulations on your
Victory here in the US Junior um tell us
a little bit about the game how did it
start were you surprised about your
opponent's opening uh yeah I started
with D4 and he normally plays Knight F6
and well he played a few games with E4
G6 so I expected G6 but I didn't look at
it too seriously uh if we can go back to
the start um yeah I prepared this line
uh with like Bishop D3 and queen E2 so
you prepared all of this actually with
Queen E2 yeah and then after a Castle's
rookie I spent like 15 minutes because I
didn't want to look like an idiot after
E5 was like I wasn't really sure what to
do after E5 you mean here in this
position yeah cuz like the engine wasn't
really showing it it showed like E6 so I
think I can like take and then take on
E5 and D5 and play Rook D1 that's
exactly what the computer recommends and
then I don't know it was complicated
like after Queen A5 I was looking at B4
Queen d8 and then like wow you were
definitely looking at a lot of
variations here B4 is correct to Queen
d8 and then like Bishop C4 and after E4
I think I have to like sack The Rook but
it's pretty complicated but I felt like
I should be doing fine after you want
after E4 you have to sacrifice a rook
here Knight takes E4 Bishop takes A1
yeah and like Bishop D5 I mean I have
like tremendous compensation it's very
complicated definitely but the computer
does say you're somehow winning in this
position I guess Bishop takes F7 very
strong threat C3 also probably yeah I
think probably after like Queen C7 I
have C3 which just wins Queen C7
probably the move or Knight D6 I don't
know G5 seems like there's a lot of
winning ways but yeah very nice Rook
sacrifice there you had to calculate now
he got into a lot of trouble very
quickly and now this spin that you're
able to manage here on this diagonal
seemed to be just
a nail on the coffin yeah I think it's
quite bad for him because if he ever
plays like C5 I have Knight D5 so
his Bishop's already pretty bad and I
mean I can play C5 myself and it's it's
quite tough for him I mean it could be
holdable but it's difficult it seemed
like a very clean game we just had a
quick question on the move before you
decided to actually take on E5 with the
Rook that kind of s that kind of
surprised this a little bit is there any
reason you decided not to move the night
away well I mean I kind of got confused
cuz if we uh go back a bit like I didn't
really expect Queen G7 I expected um
like G5 here right then Bishop G5 Bishop
G Queen G5 F4 Rook E4 and I have to like
sack my queen so let's look at this line
real quick takes takes takes you say F4
very interesting position rookie E4 is
four now he can try like B4 but I think
I have rookie one and it's just B4
rookie one and what was this sacrif
check I think Knight F3 check uh if he
takes and then Rook takes E4 Knight
takes
E4 and then like Rook G8 and I can uh
take G8 and then play like Knight F6
check ah Knight F6 first maybe Rook D7
also possibility D7 yes King f and then
like after Rook D7 I'm probably just
like checking him somehow it seems very
difficult for him to defend yeah
especially with like the bishop up here
the peral problem so you've got a little
confused and after Queen G7 like somehow
I thought like after G5 it was the same
thing but after like Bishop B uh or
maybe Rook yeah yeah probably just
Bishop B5 um after G5 Bishop B5 yeah D5
Bishop B5 and then takes takes and I
have like Queen D3 at the end right
after green D3 uh and then Rook takes
Rook takes leaves H7 track made at the
end all right so you got confused and
after B4 decided you didn't want to move
the night yeah so I just went into like
this winning end game mhm um I don't
think it should be very difficult but I
mean it I had to spend more time trying
to win it absolutely but it's still a
very clean Victory here for a wander who
starts off fantastically with the white
pieces well congratulations and good
luck with the remaining rounds here at
the US junior thank you it's just like I
always said I was saying it all day
after round one a wonderer and asosi
will be in tied for first just them that
was exactly your prediction exactly yeah
one of many by the way that we recorded
yeah I haven't recorded we covered we
covered all the angles all the possible
results uh but we have to admit that
today was really a bloody day this the
cross table might be a bit lying a
little bit when you see three draws and
only two decisive games uh and we look
at the standings as they are right now
we see that indeed ostrovski and leang
are leading with one point everybody
else have drawn and Michael bodock and
Nicholas chea who have lost are in last
place but of course there's eight more
runs and lots of chest to be played um I
think it's also worth mentioning uh what
they're playing for as far as the
monetary rewards fun right rating no
rating no money nothing no other that
small detail of a free entry to the uh
closed us Championship with a minimum of
like a $4,000 L prize hey those prizes
look pretty good too and yeah when you
look at this and again for those of you
who might have not been here at the
beginning of the show I will again
mention the comment of Dutch Grandmaster
who is doing the social media Robin van
campen who uh said to me when you heard
that the first prize was $6,000 that
that was just about the first prize in
the Netherlands main yeah but but which
tournament
stronger that is a good question as well
yeah exctly I guess that now the the
level of the tournament really justifies
the prizes and look at us um first prize
$66,000 second prize $4,000 third prize
$3,000 and w tell you the prizes when I
played in my five in my five Juniors
I'll tell you all 10 prizes first prize
0 second prize 0 third prize Z actually
I thought the first prize was a week in
Philadelphia and second prize was two
weeks in Philadelphia that's correct
also okay but before we uh close the
show why don't we go to Alejandra for
some final thoughts it was a crazy round
we saw a lot of mistakes I think the
game that exemplified it the most was
Luke harmer vot against Kaden Trove many
many errors in that game finishing in a
peaceful result at the end overall a
very exciting round and I hope this
continues in the next coming games dto
from both Ben and myself and uh please
join us tomorrow at uh
12:50 uh Central Time the games will
start promptly at 1 pm central time and
we will be back here with uh uh Grand
Masters Ben fold and Alejandro Ramirez
this is a re Freedman don't miss it we
promise you lots more Bloodshed on the
board please be with us tomorrow
[Music]
by